firing chair i had a few problems
we're now live on youtube according to
my screen just a few seconds chair
on youtube
if everybody's muted then good morning
uh everybody good morning to members of
public good morning to anybody viewing
this plans committee meeting of the 6th
of august
on youtube on the torres youtube site
good morning to all our committee and
officers here
right
right i didn't know who was speaking
them but please stay muted
um i'd like to welcome you all to this
virtual meeting with the plans committee
and i'll just go through some basic
rules of this meeting but first of all
i'd like the committee and officers to
introduce themselves so
if we could work if somebody if you
could just mention the cancer and then
can introduce themselves
and then the officers please yes chair
thank you
council about barton yeah richard bowden
i represent um heartland ward
councillor brown good morning i
represent great torington
chancellor christie good morning i
represent biddeford north
councillor craigie good morning i
represent benefit east councillor
leather
yes good morning i represent northern
good morning i represent two moors uh
two rivers and three moors
councillor golf good morning everybody i
represent biddeford north
councillor watson uh
i represent broady and councillor
wiseman
hello there um i represent the chevy
langtry ward
that thank you now if you meet
yourselves again please and would the
officers present please introduce
themselves
starting with sean i think good morning
i'm shaun harrington i'm the development
manager
at torres district council
hello i'm stacey dorey i'm the senior
special terrorist monitoring officer for
torridge district council
morning i'm chris evely planning officer
good morning i'm helen smith development
management team leader
hi savi hello um i'm sarah chapel
i'm the conservation officer at torridge
and good morning i'm rachel webb
strategical officer at orange district
house
and that's it i think we've got matt
collins from the county council highways
good morning matt collins devon county
council highways there we are
that's everybody i think now hi chris
sorry we
should also have joshua lewis hopefully
he's in here i don't know if he wants to
quickly introduce himself to everybody
hi sorry yeah joshua lewis flood and
coastal risk officer democrats council
lovely thank you that's everybody then
um at the start of the meeting we'll
mute all microphones except nine
please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked by me
to speak please residents who want to
exercise their right
have been asked to speak at this meeting
have been asked to register in advance
and also have they've had the option of
sending
their statement to us which will be read
out by an officer
or have been sent a link to temporarily
join us to speak
in person once they've finished speaking
they'll be removed as a
participant in the meeting and can view
and listen by youtube but actually
we've been asking them to remain muted
and stay
in the meeting we've got six persons
registered to speak today it was ten but
that'll be explained in a
little while and while they're only six
now
to indicate to me you would like to
speak or propose a second emotion
please press the raised hand raise the
hand symbol
in the participants menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they're passed so
i'll work through that order and i will
deal with them in that order given the
appropriate
officer or counsellor the opportunity to
answer
in between where necessary i will also
return to the counsellor to check
that they're happy with the responses to
ensure clarity and accuracy during the
virtual meetings all votes will be cast
via a verbal recorded vote and names
will be read out in alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
unmuting and muting your microphone as
necessary
for those members of the public watching
this does tend to
drag the meeting out a bit because where
we're sat in the town and we'll put our
hands up
you can soon see that but when the clerk
has to read through everybody it does
take a little bit longer so bear with us
on that
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council as you
council's youtube channel and those of
you
on there now know that anyway we are in
unprecedented times and i ask you all to
be patient during this meeting
and to understand that processes and
advice
may take a little longer and i just
mentioned that
we've now introduced everybody so we'll
go to the agenda then and the first item
on the agenda
is apologies for absence please sandra
no apologies chair
we're a full house this morning uh item
two on the agenda
is the minutes of the previous meeting
of the second of july
on pages four to eight if somebody would
like to
propose those if you're happy with them
well i'll propose them from the chair
we've got pages for
say you've got a few hands raised my
hand
i don't know tim savages no
counselor watson well if you're if
you're proposing it i'll second it
i was going to propose thank you
right that's it all the other hands have
disappeared no thank you right
it's been proposed by me and sent me by
councillor watson
that we accept those minutes of the 2nd
of july sandra could you go to the vote
please
yes thank you chair council about him
i'm abstain councillor brown
agree councillor christy
agreed canceller leather
for counselor lock or
pencil mcgolf i abstain due to my
wi-fi connection being lost that day
thank you
thank you councillor watson
thank you chair that's two abstentions
and
seven four
well there's except that's right that's
correct
right item three is declarations of
interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest
when the item is being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who've
considered
a planning application by virtue of
their membership of that council
uphold a personal interest and are
deemed to have considered the
application
separately and the expressed views of
that council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
and for members of the public that's
because
we only get all the details of
everything at this
full plans committee meeting unlike the
tournament parish councils
who because they consider it earlier
don't have all the relevant
information sometimes item four
on the agenda is to agree agreement of
the agenda between parts one and two in
it there is no part two
but at this stage i'll just bring
forward with the permission
of the rest of you the application for
torrington for great torrington the
sydney street car part one
one oblique zero zero seven zero 2018
an outline application we've had a
very late representation from historic
england on this
that came in at the 11th hour yesterday
which i was very unhappy about because
our planning officers have been in
contact with historic england
and they've not shown much interest in
making a formal response until yesterday
the day before this meeting is to take
place so i'm proposing that
we'll have to defer this application
today
because it's only fair that our planning
officers can respond to it
and it may affect the report that the
officer had put forward
and likewise the applicant's got to be
able to consider this
and be able to respond to it so i'm
going to move that
i'll propose that this is deferred
councilman goff you've got your hand up
thank you mr chairman yeah just for the
interest of transparency i'd like to
second your proposal
thank you councillor watson
yes jack could could you just enlighten
us as to why
they've come in such a late hour well it
seems a third party in great torrington
contacted them on monday i believe
on the fourth uh perhaps asking them why
they not made a proper response
um and as i said then they did put this
response in yesterday
four pages of it which i really was
angry at that because it had plenty of
as i said this is a 2018 outline
application
and i do know that our planning office
have been in touch with historic england
previously and they've shown little
interest in making any
formal response until yesterday so
but i would i would i can't really
insist but i would
definitely want this to come back to the
september meeting
once it's been considered it's all right
they'd give a response chair
but uh but they gave a response over the
over waitrose
well this yeah but that's a separate
application with diplo
different implications for that
application
that was a full application as well but
yeah i mean yeah they did made a
response years ago to the weight rose
application
yeah exactly so why didn't they make a
response when they knew about this they
were notified of this
application but as i said it was only
yesterday
that they put this response in
i think it's a disgrace yeah i do too
anyway it's been proposed and seconded
that we defer this one
to the september meeting can can i ask
sounder to go through everybody to vote
in favor please
a chance um
for the point of interest i am
dual-hatted
okay that's a master of clarification
thank you
thanks margaret thanks councillor brown
right sandra if you'd like to go to the
vault on this for deferment of this
application
yes thank you chair pennsylvan
uh for penciller brown
councillor brown can you hear me yes i
did say
because i was the second to be
introduced i said i wished you had it
and i am for thank you councillor
christie
councillor craigie or penciller leather
four chancellor lock or
pencil mcgoff or chancellor watson
reluctantly for chancellor wiseman
well we don't seem to have much choice
do we fall
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you sandra
right um
well the rest of the agenda is as
published then for the planning
applications you've got
uh the dabbing hill one first and then
we've got the hollow junction one
and then there's one in south street in
great torrington
now we were going to have a break of
half an hour
uh because by the time we'd done dad and
hillary great torrington
uh one would have been probably getting
on towards lunchtime but now i think
we'll be able to go straight through
with these three hopefully
though i accept that the first one is
going to take probably a little while
and we've got speakers for that um
right urgent matters well we've dealt
with really urgent math
which was the deferral of that
application
public participation item six on the
agenda
uh i've got to advise a committee now of
any prior request to speak by members of
the public
and to advise of the details of the
council's public participation scheme
well
we have got speakers this morning we
we've got councillor james is speaking
at the for the dad and hill one first of
all councillor haines
is speaking for the northern town
council on that
uh tim savage is speaking
as a member of the public to that one
against
uh councillor town councillor lawrence
shelley
as a is speaking as a member of the
public against
will powell is is the apes
in support is the agent paul osborne is
the applicant he's speaking in support
and fourth will be council of laws to
speak
uh who is the ward member and he'll
speak last
everybody gets three minutes to speak
apart from the world memory isn't
time limited then the next one
we did have four down to speak for the
south or sydney house car park one the
tourington one
that we've deferred so the next speakers
are
two for the holiday hollywood junction
application we've got mary ross speaking
in support with the agent
and councillor hackett who's the ward
member to speak to that
counselor custody has his hand up chair
counselor christy thank you yes it was
under urgent matters actually
um i don't know how many you actually
heard the minister this morning mr
generic
yeah the future of plans can i ask can
we get
a digest of what's being suggested from
one of the planning officers because
i tried to follow him this morning and
he was all over the place i couldn't
really understand what he was talking
about
um but could i ask that we have that
digest and can i also go back to
something i asked back in february
um what um are we doing about the
heathrow decision
where heathrow was thrown out because
they hadn't allowed enough for the
climate change
i did ask at the time and our officers
said they would come back to us and
tell us about this um obviously because
of kobe
that there has been no comebacks so
could that be added to a digest of
apparently the new rules on planning
which would appear to render us
superfluous
john do you want to just respond to that
i mean the white paper has not been
published i don't think yet it's
published today
uh yeah it was published first thing
this morning i've got a copy of it
here um 48 pages of it obviously as it
was published first thing this morning
we haven't had a chance to go for it in
detail and as always it will be detail
but it will be very valuable for us to
get together with all councillors not
just councils and plans committee um
and explaining the detail in there once
your officers have digested it
and um noted about the heathrow decision
as well council christie will put
something in there about it
and just to mention councillor
christie's
comment about the heathrow on about the
climate change
uh yes that's the level we'll review
that and we'll put a comment in on that
as well
okay thanks counselor lock
yeah mom just has a quick question about
the public speakers if you said we've
got speakers for the
um holly lane application
yeah they've been informed that we're
not having a 30-minute break and they
might not join into later on
and they might miss the slot
well yeah
i don't know if they could be contacted
i think i think they're in chair i think
um
i think um murray ross is in in the
meeting at the moment and that
councillor hackett said he was going to
phone in near at the time because he's
watching right okay thanks
thanks uh john and councillor hackett
has sent round his statement in case he
has problems with connections anyway
okay right
item seven is planning applications the
information recommendations and advice
contained
in the reports are correct at the date
of preparation
which is more than ten days in advance
of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided in writing or orally at the
committee meeting
so now we'll move on to
the first application today 7a which is
application 1
oblique0076 bleep
2020 and this is reserved matters
application
and i'll hand over to chris evelyn the
planning office who will present this
one
thanks chad is there any directors of
interest
let me leave it because i can go back
sorry i had someone else speaking then
um
did you want to do declarations of
interest or shall i carry on with the
presentation
yeah well if anybody has a declaration
of incest now make
okay proper job oh i'll crack on in that
case
so planning application076
is a reserve matters application for the
appearance landscaping
layout and scale for 130 dwellings
pursuant to application one slash 1192
2015 outline which um considered
outline and reserve matters uh sorry
outline and
access so the principal and access have
already been agreed
uh this application is for appearance
landscaping layout scale
just to clarify since uh the
writing of officer report there have
been six uh six
objections covering the following points
one and 130 should be removed due to
overbearing impacts
bungalow should be provided access from
bayview road should not be allowed
flooding issues a need to protect the
environment
does not meet local need neighboring
amenity impacts
non-compliance with policy law one
highways impacts
loss of house value unclear plans and
a zoom meeting not being ideal for
an application of this nature
more updates since the writing of the
report so
it is recommended that another condition
is added
this was following conversations between
myself and the agent
any reference to play space
in the application should now be
considered as indicative only
and that's required um by condition 20
of the outline application
and also the section 106 and it will
just allow us a little bit more
flexibility
and a little bit of more room to
negotiate um
a different package of play space so
that is recommended that if members are
minded to approve they take up that
additional condition
it's also another informative uh which
is uh
just to advise um the agent and
applicant that they would have two years
to commence following the approval of
any
sort of matters
moving on um you can see the site
location plan
on your left and the outline site plan
on your right
so hopefully you can gauge from there
without me scribbling all over the plans
this is a small section of the outline
the outline was for 500 homes
and the reserve matters is what's
considered phase one
and that would be for 130 homes access
of bayview vote this is an area
location of the plan you can see uh baby
road to the north
the link road uh to the far south
partly laundry in there as well
i'm sure many of you are familiar with
the site
this is a site layout plan the area in
blue
in the bottom left hand corner would be
for a school
that has to be a service site which
devon county would take up at a later
stage
they have come back with some details on
when
it would be provided essentially there's
a number of factors
which would be considered as to when the
school be provided including
when they can get funding and how many
houses built in the local area etc but
essentially you need the school site
there to start with before they can
even really get things kicked off in the
middle of the site you see another blank
spot
that's uh that's a service site for a
care facility
and or doctor's surgery and as part of
the school site it's also worth
mentioning that there's
also a segment of that for a community
center and facility see access from
bayview road it comes in
and travels around the eastern side of
the site the primary access
and then off of that there are some
smaller roadways uh
leading down to other dwellings
there's some attenuation problems at the
bottom of the site the land slopes from
north being the high ground to the south
um
and you can see this site is bounded on
the north and western edges by
residential dwellings
this is a view of the entrance looking
west you can it's
the field entrance with linden homes
signing it
the applicants are actually bogus now
and from the entrance looking west
this is looking in the opposite
direction again
if i zoom in you can see the entrance
there
and then standing from the entrance
looking east
this is a view into the entrance you can
see the land slopes
up and then at the other side it starts
to slope down so
this is uh where the houses are built at
the minute is literally the ridge
this is viewing back out of the entrance
i see dwellings on either side
and this is the entrance from slightly
further down the field
so we're now going to go clockwise just
taking photos from this spot
so properties along the bayview boat
looking northeast
hedgerow to the east uh indicating site
boundary
there's a field of maze in the in the
distance uh that's the approximate site
boundary
you can zoom in you can see the
different color of green
that's the school site where the barn is
and uh
sort of a line from the hetero to the
trees is an approximate
uh line to where the school site is and
you can see uh
buckley laundry
and view of side of college clothes and
taylor crescent in the background and
that's looking west
the site actually goes you can see a
hedgerow there the site actually goes
beyond that hedgerow
into what i've labeled the western field
properties along bayview road looking
northeast
this is standing from down near the
hedgerow to the west separating the
fields
and it's looking uh northeast from the
northwest corner of this
bigger field
and looking south from this northwest
corner this hedgehog on your right would
be the hedgeroom which is indicated for
removal
traveling down the hedgerow at the
bottom of the headshow you have to
school
site
and looking back up you can see the
hedgerow
going up the field is that would be
removed
and then the hedgerow coming
horizontally
that's being retained and is the
approximate site boundary with the
school
site in the other side
this is standing inside the field
gateway
so you can see the western field you see
college close to your left there
and property on bayview road or just
back from baby road to the north
um existing boundary treatment to the
top of the field
showing hetero screening
and a panoramic view of the field uh
showing
college close taylor crescent background
buttercream laundry to your left in the
school site
and top of the field to
to the far right of the photo
this is the southwest corner of the site
you can see
the western field and the school site
here
with buckley audrey would be on your
left but it's out of shot
and you can see college close taylor
crescent et cetera and behind
this is looking up the site you can see
properties along bayview road there
and then from the southwest corner of
the site
same location looking northeast
so this is the other side of the field
to the south east and boundary
uh looking up this hetero boundary which
would be retained
and it's looking north towards bayview
road in the reservoir that's the highest
point of the land there the reservoir
southeast boundary of the site looking
north west
southern boundary of the site looking
west
he's uh eastern boundary of site so this
is halfway up the eastern boundary
looking at bayview road
from the top of the field to the
northeast corner looking back south
northeast corner of the field looking
southwest you can see the sea in the
background and taylor present
blackley laundry will set your left
northeast corner looking west
northeast corner looking northeast
you can see about so far there in the
background
northern boundary looking along the
backs of bayview road
and that's it for the inside visit so
now go out of the site
this is the frontage of bay view vote
there's
a section of highway which is required
by condition which would look along this
reservoir frontage on you
just as the pavement ends on your right
it would be a build out onto the highway
uh bayview road reservoir frontage
looking east
and again further along the road same
same angle this is looking back the
other way
um so you can see this corner in the
road and this is where the pavement
would start on
on the left-hand side of the road
traveling around that corner which is
um already a difficult part to negotiate
as a pedestrian
and then coming back the other side of
the site entrance this is just showing
um an existing crossing on bayview road
there has have to be a couple
improvements
existing crossings which include tactile
paving
so you can just see like the pedestrian
crossing there
to that side for example that would need
new tactile paving
so it's friendly for all users including
disabilities
this is a wide review of the site from
the abbott stream junction
you can kind of just start see if i draw
on it
[Music]
the site is actually
above there so the field of maze ends
there
you can see the field and then baby road
along the ridge line
and so it just gives you an idea of it
in its landscape context
zoom back out sorry about scribbling on
everything
um there's an underground pumping
station which is required
uh to the south of the site um and that
will go just approximately there
just beyond the trees
and this is a view from the other side
so this is the where the underground
pumping station would be
and that would pump file sewage and it
would also have some
storage facility
this is going back to the site layout
plan uh we've finished with the photos
now
so we'll run through the plans i've
already explained that one so won't uh
luck on it too much
this is the 10-year plan it shows the
split between apartments two beds three
beds four beds and five beds
um the dots are for the affordable
housing
so um you have some traveling up through
the site there
and then some over this side as well
to the elevations so um
there's quite a few plans so these are
three bed dwelling just give you a taste
of
what's going on site four bed dwelling
three bed dwelling
one bedroom flats
two bedroom property
two bedroom property
four bedroom house
two bedroom house
free bed
free bed
another free bed
and again and again
it says different size and shape three
bed
another one full bed
different full bed five bedroom property
three bed two bedroom flats
the garage elevations
single garage elevations i believe
that's it for the elevation drawings
it's a materials plan and the site split
into three
different areas so the gateway area
family area and parkland area
and so it just gives an idea of the
proposed materials down the bottom
[Music]
the we keep going
there's character areas so as indicated
on the materials plan
and if you've read my officer report
area split into character areas so
family
zone gateway and parkland zone so the
family zone's
slightly less informal um the gateway
site
is to create an entrance in the parkland
area is a more
formal layout and each area will
have its own material palette and skin
landscaping to make it
distinctive
these are indicative street scenes just
to give you an idea of
what they would look like sometimes
elevations can be a little bit clunky
and also they don't realistically show
where
a semi-detached dwelling will be
semi-detached so
a two-bed might look quite monolithic
whereas it's actually just a
semi-detached house
um so these this is the gateway site as
you come
in so elevations a and db
so if you're looking left and right
uh this is if you came into the site uh
and then turned around
so these would be uh backing onto baby
road
um these are into the site and
straight in front of you so you can see
the parkland
character on top and the family's own
character on the bottom there
so
this is as we travel around the site so
uh
you've got these f g and h and doesn't
look like it's come on the best quality
and zoom i'm afraid so
but this is to the eastern side of the
site coming down the hill
along the bottom of the eastern side of
the site so the parkland zone
and then this is along the bottom of the
family zone
to the western side of the site
again bottom of western zone
an artist and pressure looking north
west of what what the scheme might look
like
an artist's impression of the gateway
uh this is a plan showing neighboring
boundary distances
um so the nearest boundary is
is that one there on college close it's
24.8 meters
from vietoria
this is an idea of boundaries along
bayview road as well the nearest being
this one 24.9 meters as you come into
the site
and usually as of all the farm members
will know that
we accept 21 meters so everything is
open above that 21 meter
rule of fun
this is the landscape master plan
okay this is a supporting document for
landscape master plan
and again it's quite difficult to see to
see it on zoom so
members would have been expected to look
through and appraise all the plans
in very detail prior to this meeting
the landscaping plan um there's even
more detail again and that's split into
five
separate plans which i've run through
now
so again going through the site this is
by the entrance
traveling east around the site you can
see the attenuation ponds
uh this is the um the north west of the
site
southwest of the site
south of the site
uh this is the details of an entrance
wall or the wall at the site entrance
that's proposed
um so it's a two meter high wall which
um was requested and that will hopefully
protect
existing amenities from walkers et
cetera that will be on the pavements
this is a diagrammatic drainage plan so
um you see the drainage is taken into
three attenuation ponds and two
attenuation basins
it will then come down this suds train
under a culvert and into this existing
watercourse
and you can see there the foul pumping
station and storage facility
uh drainage is attenuated so it's not an
infiltration system so it will not soak
away
what will essentially happen is the
water will be streamed off the
site and stored and then released a
greater
or better than greenfield runoff rate
this is more detailed drainage plans
and see the pipework that would be
adopted by southwest water there running
into the
attenuation basins
this is the other side of the site
and then this is the what they label the
suds train
um running down and that will filter the
water
and then it will go under a culvert in
the high a
new culvert in the highway into an
existing watercourse
buckley laundry there on your left
this is flood exceedance routes this is
how the water comes to the site as
existing so
all comes off uh to the uh
south west so it rains from north east
to south west
you can see some of it drains into
college close and some of it trains into
existing ditch and culver
and then below there's uh proposed
exceedance roots
now what that means is if the drainage
were to fail that
indicates where the water would exceed
from so
you can see some of it would go straight
down
south into the drainage
or the studs train and some of it would
go into the existing ditch
and uh past the culvert it's not
anticipated that that will fail as
as indicating devon county's
flood risk response however
they need to plan for that it's it's a
policy requirement so
that's the plan
this is the approximate waterway route
coming from the site so once it drains
into the
water existing watercourse this is the
route it should take coming into pity
food
this is the highways layout so you'll
see um
it comes in the the site entrance the
principal
route through the sites labeled red that
would be the potential bus
route through the site and it's being
tracked et cetera so it's perfectly
suitable for that
in blue you'll see some slightly smaller
codes
which help with navigation so if you're
going through the site you
generally want to travel on the
principal site and then
if you're going off into cul-de-sacs etc
then
that's just a simpler way of doing it
and generally consider good design
these are the off-site highway works
these are uh as i say indicative
uh these are the ones along bayview road
so it's just showing
um where the highway would come past the
reservoir
and then there'd be a small pinch point
coming around the corner
the large majority would be a um
still a two-way highway however there is
that pinch point where there's likely to
be
a build build-out and then probably
a a one-way or not one way but a
multi-directional system where you'd
have to give way
and then further down to the east to the
western side of bayview road
as mentioned previously there's some
tactile crossings that are required to
be improved or just installed altogether
and they're indicated there
that's the phasing plan uh so this
this site uh has access from uh
baby road it will provide some uh
highways improvements to bayview road
and then there's
numerous on-site facilities etc it also
provides
uh 21.5 affordable housing
that's set out in the um
section 106. um it's likely phase two
will be
this southern phase here and that
requires uh
what's labeled the primary access off
buckley road along with improvements
and then the final phase would then be
the eastern phase which is up here
and then that also includes a potential
pedestrian
link through that area there
the main plane considerations uh
dictated by the reserve matters
which include layout scale appearance
and landscaping
as part of these members will have to
consider neighboring amenity drainage
ecology phasing and on-site highways
um approval was recommended subject to
conditions
and are passed back to chair to
introduce the speakers
thank you
thank you chris for that thorough
presentation
well our first speaker to this
application
is councillor peter haynes and he's
speaking on behalf
of northern town council so councillor
haims you've got
three minutes once you settled in to
speak
and members northern council considers
this would not be a sustainable
development under para 14 of the mppf
for the following reasons
it would have a significant adverse
visual impact on surrounding countryside
particularly because of the proposed
housing on the sensitive skyline part of
the site
which because of its hype and proximity
would adversely affect the amenities of
neighbouring properties in bay view road
members are concerned too about the lack
of diversity and design and materials of
the proposed houses and the failure to
reflect varying character of surrounding
properties
contrary to policies dv 70 dvt-7
in terms of the mix of dwellings members
regret the lack of bungalow provision
given the high proportion of older
residents in the area
northern councillors also regret the
missed opportunity to optimize energy
efficient
efficiency and to contribute to carbon
reduction by providing
terrorist housing and incorporating
solar panels in the development
and i'll refer here to local plan policy
st-16
it's also noted with dismay that yet
again there is a failure
to provide the 30 percent affordable
housing which is required in the local
plan
we also have great concerns about
infrastructure provision
it would appear that the school medical
facilities will only be
provided at a later phase of the
development
and similarly highway improvements to
buckley road together with access to the
development from that road
given the population and highways impact
of 130 houses plus other dwellings which
have been built or have permission
in the area it is vitally important that
the required services are in place
as it stands the lack of them
contravenes policy st
20 23 calling for developments to
provide
or contribute timely provision of
infrastructure
in this connection it's noted yet again
you are presented with a partial
creeping development of the site
rather than the comprehensive
development stipulated under policy nor1
concerning transport there's concern
that the local plan requirement to
provide suitable transport links under
policy st 10 and reduced reliance on
cars
in line with climate emergency targets
under sto3
has not been sufficiently catered for in
this car dependent development
there's no nearby bus link and no
indication there will be in the near
future
and pedestrian and cycle access to local
service distant local services
is difficult especially in bay view road
which is narrow
and likely to become dangerously
congested
councillors also have serious concerns
about impact of traffic on the dangerous
five-way junction at the end of buckley
road
northern councillors do however regret
the removal in the plan of the footpath
link at the western end of bayview road
while as to cycling the section 106
contribution to the kenwood
valley cycle route is welcomed but this
should not lead
to delaying this very important project
and i ask you to wind up police council
of james
uh there's concern about the entrance to
the development and the wall
as to what it how high it will be etc
um on the subject of wildlife members
are concerned about the
impact on that and that there will be a
blocking effect of fencing on wildlife
corridors finally we share concerns
about flooding in the area in this
critical drainage area
and we refer to future patterns of
heavier rainfall
under climate change and it will appear
local planned policy s203 has not been
respected with regard to this
for all these for these reasons northern
councils recommend refusal
thank you thank you councillor haines
our next speaker speaking against the
application
there's a member of the public tim
savage
mr savage you've got three minutes also
thank you
if you'll unmute yourself thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today mr chair
i've got three points that i'd wish to
make college close residents and the
residents of south north cottage and
duckingham palace have all raised
significant objections based on the
potential flood risk
from the numerous springs that occur in
the lower part of the field next to our
properties
we remain concerned that the risk that
these springs and their known floating
of properties will increase because of
this development
and that those risks have been ignored
and overlooked by the developer and dcc
flood teams
the bund position currently does not
protect our property so we've seen no
evidence of testing in this area despite
numerous photographs being sent in
to show the scale of the issue indeed
the testers when seen
specifically ruled out testing in the
lower corner as they said the developer
didn't want to test there
the residents would like to see a proper
band or devon bank appropriately located
in this lower corner
secondly there has been some mitigation
of davey rosen's concerns about the loss
of privacy particularly near the
proposed entrance
no amendments have ever been made to the
plans to address the concerns of college
close residents and their loss of
privacy noise pollution and visual
immunity
my property number seven and others to
the right of my property do not have any
hedge line
and at no stage of the plan show us how
our loss of privacy and huge loss of
visual immunity
will be ameliorated both during the boot
build phase
and upon completion personally i would
like to see a permanent 1.8 meter fence
built along our boundaries before work
commences
which will at least offer some
protection from the noise pollution and
loss and privacy in my garden and
property
and those of my neighbors the nearest
proposed property
number 108 on the plan is less than 10
meters from my bounty on the steepest
slope
on the whole development i my neighbours
will be completely overlooked by nine
meter high houses with no privacy
protection
and no bun to prevent flood runoff
finally mr chair the access route into
phase one is via bayview road
large lorries and vehicles will have to
negotiate either a dangerous junction at
stanwell hill
into bayview road or a tight small
junction from atlantic way
neither are safe and suitable for
constant construction traffic
access and egress from college close is
already challenging due to the speed of
vehicles turning into bay view road from
stanwell hill
and the extremely short distance from
the junction to the college close turn
the council should now insist on
ensuring that all phases of this
development are accessed by the proposed
new route from buckley road
and the proposed improved improvements
to buckley road are carried out
immediately
the developer and the council cannot
continue to hide behind the position
that this is not their issue
but one for future developers to sort
out the safety of my neighbours and
residents must not be compromised
by this phase one development thank you
for your time
thank you mr savage thank you now our
next speaker
uh is again a member of the public or
he's a
northern town councillor is mr
councillor lawrence shelley if
councillor shell is there
he's speaking against the proposal
i don't know if he's here actually it
doesn't look as if he's here yes he is
true he just needs to unmute himself
all right yeah oh there yeah if you'd
like to unmute yourself
councilman shelley you have three
minutes
thank you
he's remuted can you mute mr shelley
please
that's it can you hear me yeah right
right speaking as a member of the public
i am sorry to say that this development
does threaten to fail the community the
environment and any sustainability test
the achievement of sustainable
development being the central plank
and purpose of the planning system
though regrettably
halfway down the torridge list of
material considerations
all proposed dwellings are houses no
bungalows yet westwood hoe and northern
have a preponderance of people over 60
well above levels in torridge this
development has not been designed to
meet their preferences
or the needs of anyone with mobility
problems
a poultry 21.2 percent of affordable
homes
does little to help the less well-off
either
or make it more possible for the younger
generation to stay in the area
this development is no model of
sustainability
for either generation nor does this
proposal enhance the environment
yet uniformity of roof heights and
alignment
is out of all contexts with adjacent
properties
which are a varied mix of houses and
bungalows some converted
this divergent shows up worst of all at
the most environmentally sensitive part
of the site
the highest level the regimented lines
of houses standing to attention
seen from miles around will forever be a
blot on the landscape
the deer park development nearby shows
how much more pleasant
is an aspect of varied roof lines and
orientations
the choice of materials makes matters
worse with largely rendered finishes
and little brick but much more timber
style cladding
very little evident in surrounding
properties
this proposal can make no claim to
reflect local character
if the design and layout fail to meet
the present needs and interests of the
community
they also fail to address future needs
and environmental concerns given that
the roof pitches largely
face south on the south facing site
this was an opportunity to incorporate
solar panels
as a valuable contribution to reducing
carbon emissions
no such provision has been made nor have
terraced houses been included
to optimize energy efficiency the future
is uncertain
this development makes it even more so
with serious question marks over the
provision of infrastructure
the local plan policy st 23 requires the
timely
provision note timely of physical social
and green infrastructure
with funding constraints there is no
certainty as to when or even
if the school will be built yet local
schools are full to capacity
even if built there's no guarantee of
safe passage for pupils and parents with
little or no continuous walkway
approaches
but in what shapes up to be a car
dependent community
highway improvements to buckley road and
beyond will not take place until phase
two begins
which may be years away to conclude a
three-minute limit precludes mention of
other unsustainable aspects
what most concerns me is the lack of
vision in the design of this development
in meeting the needs of the community
and in addressing environmental concerns
if approved and setting a precedent for
other phases
i really fear for the well-being of our
community
and with this spread of an alien
suburbia the progressive erosion
of the unique environmental qualities in
this area that so many residents
treasure thank you thank you councillor
shelley thank you for that
um right our next speaker is in support
is the agent
willie pahala
and you have three minutes as well thank
you good morning
uh my name is philipp hall i'm director
of trace design
and would like to summarize the approach
to highways
and drainage design the proposed highway
layout and drainage design have been
informed by the consented outline
planning commission
which was granted in february 2018
as well as challenging site topography
comprising steep gradients
the outline planning information was
based on provision of two access points
and phase one development is access of
baby road to the north of the proposed
development
which would be a secondary access once
the whole development is implemented
the design of the internal highways
allows provision of bus service through
the development as well as a
combined footway and cycleway pedestrian
and cycle lanes are
provided to bayview road as part of the
off-site highway improvement works
associated with the proposed development
a new footway will extend to the east of
the access junction
providing continuous pedestrian route
along bayview road
greatly improved improving safety of
pedestrians
the drain strategy of the outline
plumbing consent comprises a series of
above ground alternation structures
for various catchment areas with a
discharge into the existing watercourse
which is in line with the sustainable
urban drainage guidance
phase one strictly follows the same
philosophy
and the surface water runoff will be
dealt with by provision
of three attenuation basins most of the
time the attenuation basins will be dry
and only fill up when it rains the
basins will reduce the runoff rates
below
the pre-development conditions provide
surface water treatment
enhance biodiversity and improve
amenities space
the existing typography is directing the
surface with a runoff
of the upstream catchment area to a
southwestern corner of the site
resulting in flooding
to the existing properties phase one
drainage proposal ensures that the
surface water runoff is intercepted
and redirected into the proposed nation
basins before
reaching the existing properties
reducing the flood risk
in addition a cutoff drainage with
series of londons
is proposed within this area to mitigate
impact of accidents flows
from more severe storm events and
redirect the runoff into the existing
ditch
along the western boundary further
reducing the flood risks
thank you very much thank you very much
mr powell
our next speaker for the application
is mr paul osborne the applicant
and you have three minutes as well okay
good morning
chair thank you good morning um my name
is paul ozman i'm director of
lhc design um and obviously speaking in
support
uh the proposals accord with and deliver
the phase one of the approved outline
development
and unlocking the site to provide a mix
of housing that accords
with toronto's housing need assessment
and deals with the site constraints and
other matters that are set out in the
outline
um billy's explained that we are dealing
with the existing drainage situation by
reducing the runoff's adjacent land
and then we're improving the footpaths
for pedestrians on bayview road
as well as providing the first phase of
the future access
to buckley road which a number of uh
councillors and
residents have expressed concerns about
um victory group um are the developer
they
are a combination of lyndon and bovis
and one of the top five house builders
in the uk
they're proud to have a five-star rating
from the home builders federation which
guarantees the quality
and customer service they provide to new
homeowners and
they propose should reserve matters be
granted to
start work on site this autumn and
they'll be delivering the first houses
by summer next year
which will be ensuring speed delivery of
new homes and affordable housing
in northern the reserve matters design
has been developed to accord with the
principles approved in the outline
and that includes a number of different
measures which address the concerns that
have been raised
firstly it's providing 130 houses with
the phase one access of bayview road
and as i said future access to the next
phase will deliver the connection to
buckley road
the site layout locates low density
housing and a no build zone in the
northern part of the site
where it's closest to the existing
properties all of the dwellings
are called with condition 29 of the
approved outline that requires a maximum
height of nine meters across the site
uh in all the plots the key rooms and
roofs
face south which enables benefit from
sailor aspect and for residents to
install solar panels if they need to
wish to um the scheme provides a range
of one
two three and four bit houses which meet
the identified local needs
and will deliver 28 affordable homes
which is in accordance with the sector
106
and has been supported by toronto's
housing officer
the landscaping visual mitigation
strategy sets out an improved outline
is delivered and met and the scheme
creates a landscape structure that
retains enhances existing hedgerows
improves drainage provides a play area
in the northeast of the site
forms part of a connected green
infrastructure network throughout this
site and the wider phases
and results in a net gain in
biodiversity value enhancing the
ecological value of the site
history homes are also offering a three
metre strip along the northern boundary
to neighbouring residents to increase
the size of gardens that face
south onto the development as well as
providing the land for other uses as the
planning officers
hopefully set out my final point
um the site layout landscape landscaping
architecture design has been developed
with great care
with thought to the uh context and
character of the areas and as uh
set out again there are different
character areas within the site that
reflect different qualities
uh within the site and within the
context and in the last point it's been
mentioned about the access off of
bayview road
and the relationship with neighboring
properties
the boundaries comprise two meter hybrid
walls which have been discussed with
property owners
they step down to bayview road which
allowed views along the street
and deter potential for any antisocial
behavior
in that area which was a concern from
the neighbors uh thank you for
time sharing committee um hopefully
you'll
be happy to go after planning for
consent and we're confident this
development will be a positive
contribution to northern
thank you thank you mr osborne our final
speaker to this is the board member for
westwood hall councillor nick laws
the laws uh thank you chair
i am full of admiration for the people
who've just spoken
uh the only weakness in their argument
is that they
have to pack so much into three minutes
um i'm not gonna do that i'm going to
concentrate we'll just take
one issue at a time and i won't be too
late
um the bottom western corner
which has been ignored by everyone i
didn't actually see a picture of it
either
this is below the new uh flood relief
ditch the lower one there's then a
triangle of land falling
and a butting um
19 college close
now this has been an issue taken
seriously
uh for nearly two years i visited this
site
and climbed onto this hedge with
uh the past leader of torridge
councillor
whitaker and what we witnessed there
could only be described not just as a
spring
but it was a water feature in in my
backyard and i'd love to have it
it was bubbling out of the ground now
the properties of ducking and palace
and the cottage adjacent to it and 19
have all been subject to a change in
pattern
by the springs now when
we when the developer digs foundations
and then puts roadways in etc you're
basically going to hold
you're going to put a lid on the springs
in those areas
which is only going to make it worse for
the people
in this very low corner now there have
been pictures
they've circulated it of water bubbling
out of the ground
now it's a little tiny area this the
developers
have had i don't know how two years
to put this one little issue to bed what
they don't realize is
the worry that they're concerning to one
person well three
lady ducking palace the adjacent cottage
and number 19
because their gardens fall away
from the head the natural hedge
they've asked for a piece of bundy this
is
really only a small area the developers
don't seem to realize the stress that it
causes
and this happens in endless planning
commissions and we need to concentrate
one little area now south mall cottage
their garden you step
onto the lawn this isn't as a result of
the development this is fact as it is
now
and you literally like it feel as if
you're walking on a sponge
the same as ducking and palace now
they're talking about taking water
away from the site down the ditch at the
uh
western edge this is a ditch that
members should really
see it's totally inadequate it's not
cleaned out
it's just a very small ditch
this could have to take a lot of water
now it's interesting to see that the
um the artist's impression of that
lower part of the site showed the water
retention
um scheme that the ponding
but i noticed that it was just shown as
grass
now we have one of these on buckley road
on the other estate
and then what concerns me is you put in
these shallow pools
maximum depth of that one i think is
0.92
meters and um
you said they're not fenced how
dangerous just because they're only
going to be an occasional use children
love to play in places like that
it just it just concerns me and and only
on on a wider scale what concerns me is
below this side eventually you come down
to the kenworth power
now i've had a meeting with devon flood
people and they tell me that the
responsibility
of keeping these culverts and waterways
clear
doesn't lie with the developer of the of
this
um it's not his thought he's not
responsible
it's the people that they run through
you can take lenward
as an example which is just off this
site but will be developed
it's totally blocked uh and it's
it's begging for a lincoln and for the
ancient people here
lincoln and limbo where the upper stream
blocked
and then suddenly there was a surge of
water
and if we go to the top of the site and
i'll finish very shortly chair
the top of the site when we when we look
at the properties now i've had more
representations on on this than any
other
is why you know i mean the developer
they want to do beautiful things they're
they're
architects they're planners they want to
do beautiful things so what do they do
they don't
put bungalows uh at a good distance
uh away the distance is fine but they've
got
houses which are going to look down into
people's
uh and into people's bedrooms uh
i just feel ill conceived there
uh yeah it's inside the development
boundary
i've got nothing against the the
application
what i have uh is is that all the
details
uh peter haynes summed it up the design
aspects
uh you know the lack of natural stone
the lack of
um fitting in you know fitting in
is is something we should be considering
and i know
but my main concern when i go down to
the bottom corner of that site
such a small area affecting so
few people but they're people that are
really worried
thank you chair thank you for your time
thank you council laws
can i just ask chris to zoom in on one
of the plans showing that corner that
counselor laws was referring to
and perhaps chris you could just explain
what is intended to do
uh one of the speakers talked about uh a
devon bank along there
some kind of a bund along there what
kind of
drainage to to pick up any springs that
flow through into
the gardens from there can you explain
what is proposed there
i see that there's a culvert proposed
okay uh chair thanks um so
uh brief uh geography lesson i'm sure
peter christie will um
put me in my place in a minute um but a
spring
is uh merely where water
uh soaks away into land and then where
is the spring
is where that water re-emerges from the
land
okay so the whole idea of this drainage
strategy is it doesn't use
an infiltration system so it doesn't
allow water to soak away
so as all of this water let me
edit edit the site all of this water up
here
will essentially be where it would have
previously
soaked away and re-emerged at this
bottom corner
here it will no longer have that
opportunity
it will be cleaned off the site be
stored in attenuation basins
and therefore um in theory the springs
should be have a significant
benefit and a betterment they may not
even be swings anymore
um there is a small uh
let me get rid of that
delete that this corner here so there is
buns uh that they're proposing which is
this green line
so because of the way the land goes
everything to the uh
that's downhill of that essentially
cannot be caught
uh you'd have to catch it in a pond and
pump it back
uphill but that is a very small section
of the site it's
a small triangle where the swings emerge
there's existing
planting there and that planting will be
enhanced
we have confirmed if devon county
council they are here if you have any
technical questions but we have
confirmed will this
be acceptable it is acceptable um it's
unfair to say we've ignored
uh comments i've asked devon county
directly for their comments
on that particular corner of the site
and they've replied
and said that it's acceptable um
there isn't a new a new culvert here um
the new culver is much much further down
the site
and that's on laundry lane
so that goes underneath laundry lane the
main bulk of the
water um let me give it this
and go back a slide the main bulk of
water will be
as i say captured off the site
into these attenuation basins will
travel down here
and go under the new culver into the
drainage
so if hopefully that clarifies it but if
it doesn't
i can bring in josh lewis and devon
county council flood risk
uh who i'm sure is much more qualified
to talk about drainage
and how it works thank you chris
right i i'll throw it over to the
committee now i'll see council and
oxford
to speak yeah just a couple of points to
begin with
um page 11 section 106.
um either one was really pleased that
they are still continuing with their
21.8
percent of homes because as we all know
in lots of larger applications um the
applicants seem to go to the dvd
um to try and say it's not viable
that they don't have to supply any
affordable homes so i'm really pleased
to see that at least there will be 28
affordable homes which i think
our strategic enabling officer has
agreed with
is that my first point second point
on page 42 highways can i ask matt to
come in
with the implementation of the new
footpath how does this affect the width
of the highway please
that's certainly cancel heavy um bayview
road where it's narrowed will still
function as a road for two-way traffic
um
there may need to be a small narrowing
to to a single width
to ensure pedestrian safety and
visibility around that corner
that chris showed earlier um so that you
could see an oncoming vehicle
and that's a situation that
naturally happens along bayview road
anyway with a number of parked cars
then it would work in a similar fashion
with people giving and giving and taking
um and as i have to say i experience
exactly the same situation
um on roads such as sandy mare
going down to the beach there's a few
build outs there
which is a significantly busier road and
that would still work
okay just one final point then i'll let
other listen to see what other committee
members say
baseball team northern town council and
council pete names alluded to the
removal of the footpath that the western
end of bay room wrote
was this removed following the crime
officers report on page 16 or was there
some other reason for it to remove
please
hi rosemary i'll come in there and if
you don't mind um so
yeah uh it was removed because there was
significant local objection and there
was
also objection from uh the police and
crime liaison officer
as with most things in planning it is a
bit of a balancing act so
uh if you have if i can just get
site plan up a second
sorry i'm used to handling so many
slides
so this one here uh and it would have
come
in there um
so that would have been a useful link uh
in terms of
um people coming in and out of the site
um slightly easier potentially getting
to school easier
however um the police and crime leaders
and officers did object there was
significant local objection and there
was also some difficulties with
who actually owned the land etc so it's
just considered
the negatives outweighed the positives
and we removed it
and that's essentially that thank you
for that risk
thank you thanks a lot counselor christy
thank you chairman um well as we all
know this site
is in the local plan it's been in
approval um
it very much um touches on what the
minister was talking about this morning
of course
but anyway um can i ask i've got five
issues
that i want to raise um they're going to
be the different officers so if i can
take them individually the first one is
why is it only 21 affordable
okay um councillor christie i think i'll
bring in rachel there and because she
was involved with the section 106
um we that is agreed and was part of the
outline
this uh so we are just this is just
reserve matters so infrastructure is
already agreed it's not
actually full consideration at this
stage if you want a bit of background
um i can bring in rachel and she can
hopefully explain
um why that was at that time because um
i simply wasn't here
and did not deal with it would you like
that
yeah okay make sure if you'd like to
come in please
yeah morning councillors um yeah the
time of the outline application
a viability assessment was submitted to
account
so on the basis that the full planning
obligations weren't viable
uh this plan in this liability appraisal
was assessed by the district valuation
office
and it was determined at that time that
21.2
affordable housing was viable and so
that is what's detailed in the section
106 agreement that
the outline application um so that as
christian has um relayed that it's not
up for discussion at this point
um what i would say is that's actually
quite a
significant amount of affordable housing
given the significant
significant schemes we've had come
forward in recent times where we're only
achieving
five or ten percent so it's encouraging
the applicant hasn't come back at this
point
and argued that that 21.2
isn't viable um so it is in
my opinion a positive
thank you rachel councillor christie
yeah well thank you for that the it goes
back to the point i've made before that
we seem to be including sites in our
local plan where
we don't appear to have done the
groundwork uh
we say we want 30 and then we get these
uh evaluations coming so well that can't
be achieved because of the site
i think we need to revisit that in our
local plan
i'll set my second point is the section
106s can i ask which councillors were
consulted over these
sorry councillor christie the section
106 was
uh done a significant time ago um
quite the officer that dealt with it has
left
um so that's a question i simply cannot
answer
because i do not know as rachel said the
infrastructure was tied up as part of
the 2015 outline application
um it's not for discussion now
but i cannot tell you who was consulted
because i
i simply do not know
uh well thank you because i will ask
this question every time because
members have been on some time will know
that i fought for years to get
the councillors actually involved in
section 106 and i'm just intrigued
i'd like that i'd like to know that who
actually was consulted over this
um the second point about the section
106 and really this is for matt
um i'm not sure if he's still here but
um
i noticed it from the report there's
three quarters of a million pounds
virtually uh going to the traffic lights
down at the bottom of buckley at some
time
and also going to this um uh this
how can i put it bottomless pit that
seems to be haywood road roundabout
can i just ask how much is in the pot
now
from for the hayward road roundabout
from section 106s
including this site
certainly accounts for christie the
there's there is a difference between
the amount of money that's signed up
uh on section 106 is that we're
expecting and
and on sites that have actually
progressed um i'm sure you're aware
there's a number of sites that aren't
progressing
um i think the latest count is around
1.5 million
um in total towards the buckley and
hayward road
junctions um and i
i believe we are submitting the final
business case to the department of
transport for those schemes
uh today or tomorrow and hopefully
we'll be gaining approval within the
next few months and starting work from
january next year
cancer christian
dropped out there for a moment i'm sorry
i didn't get the uh
the [ __ ] out there but um can i just
suggest to matt that uh some of that
money
you might like to spend it now actually
repairing some of the uh
craters by the way roundabout because
i'm sure
many councillors get a lot of uh
comments about that
um i'm all in favor of the ken with uh
cycle route by the way for that section
106.
um i noticed there's money going to the
atlantic bracket center and also
gymnastics
uh i may be asking later how much money
they've already received because i find
that intriguing it all goes to one point
anyway can i go on to another point
about renewable energy
um again this goes back to the issue i
raised about the heathrow
walling there seems to be no uh
contribution to reducing carbon
emissions on this estate and yet
heathrow was turned down
almost on this very basis we heard uh
from several people about solar panels
and i'm just astonished that torridge is
still going ahead and allowing
um estates to be built like this with no
real
contribution to that uh i find that very
sad
uh my fourth point about drainage
we've already heard from people about
different aspects of drench can i ask
you just to turn to page 18
in our agenda
page 18 just at the bottom is the um
second paragraph from the bottom i'll
just read it out if you haven't got your
agenda handy
um it is noted that the design of based
on a now comprises a cratered
system under the basin
could explain that because this was what
we were offered once before
under the biddeford sports ground
and councillors objected
intensely because basically it means
storing
kind of stagnant water in concrete boxes
under the surface as we understood it
is that the same system that's being uh
proposed here
um essentially council christie that is
correct do you want me to bring in
joshua lewis and
we can discuss how a created system
works and exactly what it comprises of
yeah that'd be worthwhile chris thanks
joshua are you still there
yep sorry
sorry i was going to ask another
question and yes with a creative system
it depends you can have a
you could have it as concrete a concrete
tank as you said
or you could have it as plastic crates
which essentially stack up onto each
other um
to sort of form the crater system
um as a such as a tank um
i'm i'm not sure what was proposed um
for this site sorry i haven't looked at
the i'm i'm not the officer that's
reviewing the application but i am aware
there's
in one of the basins there is to be
crates beneath the base and i think
that's too
they couldn't get the full amount of
freeboard they wanted to aim for 300ml
freeboard
and the basically couldn't quite achieve
that just in the basin and so
they proposed a cratered system just
beneath the basin
yeah to achieve that
thanks joshua could you just explain
what a free board is oh yep sorry
um so you have a design level
the maximum uh water depth within the
basin and then
you have a little bit of uh
so in essence they're putting 300 ml
above
that maximum water depth so for example
to the maximum water that was 1.2 meters
they'd say right well
the basin will be 1.5 meters deep and
then
that's just sort of um the basin will
take sediments
and um vegetation will build up over
time so that's just that's given you
um sort of
a bit of additional space
thanks for that josh can i just bring in
shaun harrington here because he's got
his hand up i think he probably wants to
make some comments here uh thank you
council ever i just want to pick up
quickly on a comment from council
christi in relation to section 106 just
to clarify matters
especially in relation to officers not
consulting members which isn't the case
the section 106 in this instance was
agreed partly outline application which
was submitted in 2015 so some time ago
and i believe it is the recommendation
for approval went through committee in
2016.
um so obviously committee members would
have seen that 616 at that time
obviously we can go back through the
records in 2015 but we are looking at
five years ago
um and the section 106 was partly
outlined commission
and therefore it's not open for uh
discussions partners that matters
that we're looking at in front of you
today many things thank you
thank you can i come back here chris
i've still got two more points
well then uh well once again about the
drainage can i ask chris
uh to go back you went through uh
one slide it had a red line on it
showing drainage
actually going down to the
east i can't remember that would be the
northern stream i expect
yes that's what i was getting concerned
about
i think it was a photograph with a red
line on
that one
yes that one can you just explain what
is the red line is this
where the water is going to go
hi cancer chris hi councillor christie
that's essentially what i've
drawn on a google map showing where the
existing watercourse is
yeah right so is there extra water going
to go down there
this is going to be used by this estate
to actually drain their water is it
so there's no extra water coming down
there the existing water already comes
down there
so as a result of this development
you'll know
as a result of building on land it
doesn't result in
extra water the problem is is the speed
in which the water comes off the site
if you concrete it is much faster so
that creates the
uh the flooding problem not the amount
of water so the
the amount of water in that stream
remains the same that's where the
exceeding suits go
as existing the only difference should
now be a betterment
because of the way the attenuation
system is designed
the water will essentially be slower
getting to that stream
yep and your final point council christy
was
i think he's just lost connection chair
all right right well i'll go to
councillor craig you know
next one to speak
councillor craig you can unmute yourself
thank you chair can you hear me
yeah yeah um what i would like to raise
is the play area and you mentioned
something about that at the beginning
but i didn't quite catch what it was
um i'm concerned about where the play
area is because i wasn't quite so aware
of how mane that road was going to
be um the the access road
appears to go round to the right
um and follow down to the school
um and it doesn't appear to go there's
no
all traffic coming into the site
will have to go to the right because the
left
they're both cul de sacs so as they
uh if boss says and main traffic is
coming down that road i'm concerned are
they going to the school
is that the access site for the school
um
and the play area is therefore only
you can only access it by crossing a
very main road that we'll have
school traffic we'll have all access to
the site traffic
might have buses if we ever manage to
get any
it's not a very suitable site for a play
area the children would have to be
accompanied by adults to get to that
site
i was wondering if it would be possible
to change the play area site with the
um the the
care home site obviously the care home
site's slightly larger
but it's in a good place because when
they come out of school they could go
straight across to the play area
site and get some you know some good
exercise before they go home
and also the care home would only be
accessed by
mainly a cars um and traffic
it wouldn't there won't be many people
visiting the care home on foot
so but not um so i'm thinking this big
square in the middle
where the care home should be if they
rearranged it so they were of equal size
um it would be a wonderful place for it
the care
the care home would be fine because they
would be
um along the top and i i gather that
there's the
adjourning uh there's a
the site carries on to the east so i
understand that the play area was going
to be extended
so there would be further space for the
care home
um but my main thing is um the access to
the site is it
all coming down that road is that the
access to the school is there going to
be another access to the school
i i also regret the loss of the
walkway through i do think we have to be
sustainable i do think we have to start
thinking about how people can walk and
cycle to school
and around without having to use cars
and also this brings me on to the
sustainability i i do wish that the
the houses were of a sustainable
um kind
that's all for thanks very much thanks
chris if you'd like to address that but
i think originally the play area was
going to be over on the
on the western side somewhere originally
i think i saw a plan originally that
showed it there
but councillor craig makes the point
that any traffic coming in
has got to come up from baby road turn
left and go around that main road
down to the school site of course when
phase two
ever comes forward and is developed
traffic will come to the school up
through that from the main
entrance onto buckley road but currently
it would have to come down past that
play area
yes so uh so the access is approved on
there for 1320 that's precisely right
chris
um coming back to the play space um we
aren't agreeing the on-site um
green space now but we are agreeing
layout so i would say that no we cannot
change the positioning
i've labeled the main points of on-site
green infrastructure so
there's opposite the school there is uh
informal play space you can see
i can't zoom in whilst editing but let
me just
draw on this there's a path area there
um so that that would be
a space opposite the school and also the
sustainable urban drainage pond
in that middle has been designed so it's
less steep
than the ones either side of it so
it's anticipated that that middle
central one can actually be used
as well and it will be dry most of the
year so
um that there will be areas of green
space opposite school
um the the idea of play space
uh being on a primary route is uh
accepted in our policies that should be
in a route which is
accessible um is frontaged uh
so that it's open um and easily you know
it's easy to get to there's pavements
here
it's on the main road through the site
so in policy terms of i've got really no
issues with that um and i think it does
comply with our policy
and then there's just a small piece of
uh
land coming down to the right there
which is again
just a landscape piece of grass where um
you know people could walk their dog and
i suppose etc
so those they're the main points really
in the site
i i think they are um they are
acceptable in terms of policy and
at a later stage we can try and agree uh
via poli
via condition 20 and the section 106
um improved play facilities as well in
those areas
um the walkway um if members felt
um you know so married to they
that was a necessity we could add that
as a condition
um but um it would be my recommendation
not to
um in terms of sustainability
um council christie and councillor craig
have both raised it now
so i may as well um come back and try
and answer those points
um a few years ago the government
actually took away
some of our ability on bigger sites and
smaller sites to
encourage and allow for
more sustainable credentials within the
development such as solar panels etc
it is disappointing i i as much as any
any of you guys would love to see solar
panels on
um all of these roofs but there simply
is not the policy
backing that we have to achieve that if
we do do a local plan review or
something that might be something
which we could consider but um right now
our plan is considered new and compliant
with local and national policy
um so and unfortunately
uh or fortunately whichever way you look
at it or whichever angle you look at
the message we're receiving is build
build build rather than
um you know just try and um
you know you understand where i'm coming
from anyway i hope they're uh
they're the points so i'll come back to
you chair thanks
yeah thanks chris and just to pick up on
councillor craig's point about the play
area
i did raise that myself and we've had
clarification now from the agent
from that what's shown currently as a
local area of player lap which is very
very pathetic scheme i've got it here
i've got it here that's that's now
going to be a separate app a separate uh
agreement
it'll be a proper area of play there'll
be more equipment than
was originally envisioned in there but
our next
i'll move on to the next speaker is
councillor mcgoff
thank you very much mr chairman i got
about four or five points to go through
a piece of a mate
the first one will be on page 11 and it
comes under the
section 106s it's the the pumping
station in an attenuation points which
fall outside of the ownership
of the individual dwellings the council
or the county council
can i just have some just some clarity
of that one there
does this then become the responsibility
of the developer
or would it then fall in the scope of
the management
um system that's put in place after the
development has
been delivered you have management
companies set up
and obviously then it would become
responsibility of the house owners
itself because somebody just give me
some clarity on that please
chris yeah it's understood that the
um the on-site uh drainage in terms of
the uh the pipework etc and the pumping
station would be adopted by southwest
water
with okay thank you much for having me
chris i was hoping he was going to be
saying that to be honest
um say on page 11 please it's the
highways the buckley road widening
scheme
now what is rough what's what's the time
scale of the delivery of this widened
road and
what um which number of property does it
come into where
my 106 money is released is it the sale
of the the last house 130
dwelling sold which which stages can be
implemented because obviously this is
paramount
to begin another development itself
for the safety obviously road users and
obviously pedestrians will walk along
that road
can someone clarify that for me please
um yeah sure rach rachel you probably
have more dealings with the section 106
could you just
come in there if you know and if not
i'll turn to the
section 106. yeah my understanding is
that that
that funding isn't actually due until
the second phase so i think on the 131st
unit completion um but i think it's
really for matt collins to
to clarify that because he would have
been instrumental in the drafting of the
section 106 agreement for that aspect of
it
so um i think mike collins is probably
the best
officer to deal with that question
i think yeah matt if you want to come in
i think i think
um the correct hang on matt
it's correct what rachel says it's on
the 131st dwelling
which will be on the second phase on
once that started
but i was intrigued to hear mata collins
earlier on
say he reckons there's about a million
and a half currently
in the pot um which is it's not just
this scheme that's paying in
to this 106 or to the road improvements
but also
deer park on the other side of buckley
road that's been completed
and some of the developments on that
side are also chipping into this pot of
money
for road improvements but if there is
that kind of money currently available
i would have thought that the buckley
road improvements could come
as soon as possible really certainly
sooner than
it looked like but matt you you better
answer
thank you um i'll just clarify that i
believe the
the widening of buckley road it will be
part of the phase two
at 131st dwelling um
the works the small footwear on bayview
road i've
requested that that's done before any
house is occupied on this
phase um and in terms of the section 106
contributions from from the rest of
biddeford and northern
i said i've just just been looking up
and we have 1.5 million in signed
agreements
but no no triggers on any of those have
been met
so the deer park site didn't pay any
that went through on appeal
um a number of the other sites in say so
northu
uh windsor park and around flavelli road
they will be paying but obviously they
haven't started yet and
so we haven't we haven't got any money
coming in uh and we don't know when they
will be
coming in um so the county council is
borrowing against those
signed amounts in order to forward fund
the
buckley junction and hayward junction
also westby junction improvement
and others towards basketball south
moulton and so that should start next
year
um and we need we
we need that funding to come in through
delivery of sites
councilman goff thank you mr chairman
yeah um my personal being initially i i
don't i find it irresponsible of the
devil county council
not to implement the road winding on the
first phase of this development we all
know
that most of heavy traffic is going to
be coming down an incredible it will be
going via north and through baby road
that end
it's going to come right off of baby
roadside coming in
that's easiest point of hdv driver to
access the quickest route possible going
in
being a local person i find it
irresponsible the 131st dwelling
that's not delivering for our public at
all i i don't like that at all i'm not
in agreement with that page 16 please mr
chairman last one for a moment
this gets touched onto devon county
council again he flood risk management
which is very important to be discussing
because this one it says
at this stage we object to this plan
application because we believe it does
not
um satisfactorily conform to the policy
sto3 linked to climate change of north
devon
and torres local plan the applicant
would therefore be required to submit
additional information in order to
demonstrate all aspects of the post
surface water drainage management system
have been considered now reading through
this application itself
where is this the additional information
from the developer
it was an oversight counseling gothic if
i can draw your attention to page 18 at
the top
there's an updated flood risk management
update there where they've withdrawn
their objection
dated the 17th of uh the fourth 2020
at the top of page 18. where i where i
like to touch on
that release on that mr chairman is the
i think he's that the gay being basket
system which character christie touches
on
now you know the game your choice of
plastic as well using plastic you know
we went plastic free trying to be more
for the environment
the climate change emergency we're going
for them acceptance of plastic or make
possibility of plastic to be delivered
on the site which would be buried in
ground for
forever and a day um it's not i don't
find that good enough i'd like to come
back on
cancer okay sorry officer harrington's
comment to counselor christy
now i i gotta say i back out of christie
here
he wasn't having a goal officer saying
you don't correspond with members he
just merely asked a question
of which council's at a time working so
did
for the 106 agreements because this is
very important because actually i dare
say
now i know we've gone back five years
but war you know you're in receipt of
all this information for years
but council chris wasn't making a point
against officers and you don't
inform members but it is member-led
councillors i i totally agree with
chris all right thank you councilman
golf
uh i've not seen any more hands up to
speak at the minute
anybody else want to make any comments
counselor christy coming back or
counselor lock
climb sir christy then cancel the lock
yeah i just want to come back when i was
cut off actually yeah
we lost we lost contact with the cancer
crowd um
yeah the point i was making uh chris
actually made a really good point now
i'm glad he remembers his a level job
fit
that when you concrete over an area uh
the water moves
more quickly now we've got all these
attenuation ponds
and this all fits for this site but the
reason i was asking where the water goes
is it
it's going to end up at the bottom of
rally hill
and already in the last few weeks
there's been more work going down there
and
councillors may recall that we actually
agreed um
a development just behind rose hill it's
where councillor watson nearly got
killed by the lorry
um we seem to look at these sites
individually and i'm becoming more and
more worried that
it's a they're sort of interlocking
and it only needs one to go wrong before
all the rest is going to be a knock-on
effect and it will affect
biddeford finally in my award and
i'm just wondering these are tenution
ponds
how i've got to be i know what the
answer is
i'm going to be told yes it's all been
worked out but how safe are they because
already in biddeford we had one system
go disastrously wrong
and i'm just wondering what happens when
one goes wrong um
i've got one other point i'll raise as
well it's a very simple point we're
agreeing
the details of a new estate here can we
as a council can we impose a 20 mile an
hour limit on this estate
because um i've been approached by quite
a few people just recently it's all to
do with
cycling and everything else about 20
mile an hour limits
uh to making a state safer i'm just
wondering can the council impose that as
a condition or does that have to come
from devon county thank you
thank you uh well either march or chris
could answer that
um so i can come back under 20 miles an
hour so
uh no it wouldn't be reasonable for us
to include that as a condition
um simply because it's dealt with by
different legislations so
the condition itself isn't necessary or
realistically
enforceable we would have to send our
enforcement officer out with a
speed camera essentially which just
isn't feasible i'm afraid
so uh we would have to stick there with
whatever um
devon county impose as a speed limit um
one would
presume it's a it's an estate it's been
designed
so that it's safe so one has to presume
so
again with the attenuation um the
difficulty is
uh there that the science and the
evidence is
is telling us that it's acceptable um
planning's
often a planning's an interesting
subject because it's
um it mixes the arts and the sciences
so the arts for example you get your
subjective parts about design etc but
then you have your sciences where
you have technical data which is
evidence
so the evidence here which is
corroborated by civil engineer
and then backed up by
devon county council is showing that the
drainage
is perfectly acceptable for the site so
unless we have our own evidence to
counter that
essentially we we cannot recommend a
reason for refusal
and any reason is likely to be
considered
unreasonable i would say um
i hope that answers your points thank
you
councillor locke yeah just two small
further points
um page 34 and 35 landscaping
there's been several objections i think
regarding the proposed two meter
boundary wall near the site entrance
but i know that the comments are this
could be done by permitted development
in any case i don't think that is really
a concern
um based 36 hours of construction
refers to condition 19.
now there's no specific condition
browser construction on this application
so i'm assuming that condition 19
refers to the outline application so i'm
just wondering why there are no
construction hours condition on this
application
and also of course we know that they're
going to be um
allowed to work longer hours with these
news so i
don't know whether we could apply a
condition to this
application okay yep
thanks councillor look thank
you can i come back chris yeah you can
come back
thanks okay so sorry for clarifying uh i
should have clarified in a report
uh exactly where conditions were
relating to the outline and where they
were related to reserve matters so
apologies for that
um the condition 19 uh
notes construction it that is from the
outline
notes construction work shall not take
place other than between
7 30 a.m to 6 p.m on mondays to fridays
saturdays between uh nine and five and
no time on sundays or bank holidays
um in terms of conditions there are set
out in the
uh in national policy fairly strict
tests uh
you would have heard it mentioned and uh
we would have
spelt them out to you um or spilled them
out to you on a number of occasions so
the six
tests one of them is whether it's
necessary and you should avoid
because this is on the outline
essentially and
very simply it's not necessary to uh
reintroduce it onto this
if it did make members more comfortable
we could we could put an informative on
this condition just
so that they recognize that that is
linking back to the outline
um but it wouldn't be a necessary
condition well i think that's important
that
you add an informative so people know
where the condition came from
yeah i agree with that i do i i'm
i like to see things reinforced and i
think that reinforces
what's in the outline
right if nobody else wants to speak oh
councillor brown did you consider brown
i saw your hang up
you'd have to unmute yourself
it's quite important to me i i read that
um there are 29 two-bedroom houses
13 of them fall below the required space
room space required now if you take that
over
quite a few houses that gives the uh
the owner a lot more space doesn't it to
build more houses
but i do think that people do need
reasonable size houses they don't want
to live in rabbit hutches
so i don't think that um they should be
allowed to build in smaller rooms
thank you chad thank you good point
though
uh right well if nobody else wants to
comment at present
i'll make my comments and
i've drafted a few things here this is a
very important
a very important application and i think
everybody understands that
from the comments from the public
speakers about this i'm very
disappointed that we're not having any
bundles i really am
disappointed they should have gone that
along that top barrier with bayview road
but i'll just read out yesterday i
worked out a few things
that i wanted to say the drainage
strategy for surface water and
consideration of the scheme being
a betterment of the runoff rate that
currently exists and chris has
explained and spoken to that though
amendment
what really upset me was the amendment
to the outline permission
in the outlying permission condition 24
at little
g said a survey of the condition and
capacity
of any receiving ditch course or culvert
and including details of necessary re
repair
or improvement works be undertaken that
was deleted
as a non-material amendment now i'm
very unhappy that happened before this
new council was elected
a management plan must be submitted for
the future maintenance and management of
the system that's
in the 106 agreement and it appears that
off-site issues regarding existing water
courses and culverts
will be the responsibility of the
environment agency this has been
asked by a few people when this
when this drains across the road sulfur
road there
into the existing watercourse which we
know is the
northern stream that comes down past
lenwood
and down through the valley there as
councillor christie's
mentioned we don't know what the
condition of that stream or the
watercourse is along its length
and really when the outline was agreed
and that clause was put in the the
landowner who applied for the outline
that should have been done by the
landowner now it's being split into
three
sites for development and this is the
first phase
all that the applicant has to do is to
show how they're going to drain this
site
and where it will go to that's all
they've got they're responsible for
and and i accept what they've put
forward as
as a an acceptable drainage scheme it is
these crates that have been mentioned
under the basin of one of the
attenuation ponds they're used all the
time they're on schemes like this
they're actually being used currently
under the big car park on cleveland road
of the new b
m store they've got this system up there
and it's pumped out from there when it
when they're full they get pumped out
from there
um i'm as i've said i'm very
disappointed that this site does not
offer any bungalows
i think they really could have put along
that northern boundary
two bed detached bungalows they would
have so like hotcakes
uh there is a big demand for them um
when recent housing needs state there's
a need for bungalows in the district
it would have been an ideal opportunity
to site semi-detached two-bedroom
bungles along that boundary
which would have been more acceptable to
the residents in the area along there
and provide it and provided a better
housing mix because in the
in chris's report he states that
the proposed housing mix on this site is
weighted differently to the hedner
which is the housing and economic needs
assessment 2016
which requires a greater proportion of
one and two bedroom dwellings
nonetheless there is no condition upon
the outline planning
mission requiring compliance with the
hedonomix and thus the lpa is limited to
what it can control
now i find that amazing that because i
think the outline
application really was just to confirm
the access to this site with everything
else reserved apart from
the 106 was agreed but if we are now
being told
at outline stages we've now got to start
putting in
the types of dwellings we would like to
come forward and if we're going to put
those in at the outline stage
that's a different ballgame to what
we've been used to dealing with
currently um the potential no
this is another way man the potential
later living site the care home site
is to be marketed for two years to a
prospective operator
if it's not taken up and it may well not
be taken up there because it's hardly in
an ideal
position as far as bus routes or shops
or anything like that
if it's not taken up it may result may
result
in a further 17 dwellings being applied
for which would take this site
to 147 which is obviously 17 above the
outline permission i'd like i'd like to
know where we are with that or would
this just
remain green space if it's not sold
11 a level of 21.2 off of the site
is for affordable dwellings the section
106 states there should be
25 of one bedroom which would equate to
seven
one bedroom we're being offered just
four
with an extra two bed allocation 28
dwellings in all
there's a growing need and it really is
a growing need
for one bed accommodation and i believe
we should that we should
this should be complying with the one or
six agreement that states that what
that's what will be provided
the design and access statement mentions
a local
equipped area of play well i've
mentioned that earlier on that's going
to be
agreed separately now and be a far
better
area of play another very important
aspect of this development is the
boundary treatment
abutting existing residential dwellings
whilst there's a three metre wide strip
behind bayview road
it's not clear how this will be managed
or whether the offer of the parcels of
this strip will be accepted by the
residents in bayview road
in any event it's left to be it has to
be left clear because
there is a foul sewer that runs along
the length of that boundary so
you can't build over it in any event
you've got you've got to keep back from
that anyway
on the eastern boundary alongside
college clubs i think it's the western
boundary actually
college classes on the west
it's not clear either if there'll be a
comparable buffer zone offered to the
residents
along that boundary and i did see that
it was mentioned at 1.8 meter high close
boarded fencing
would not stop issues of overlooking
from
some of the potential new dwellings
because they're on higher
level on the site but the thing is it
would make it a far more secure boundary
so i think the 1.8 meter fence along
that boundary is needed
along with extra planting green planting
along there
i'm very pleased with the landscape
management and maintenance plan
i've got a copy here and i've read all
through and it's brilliant it's a very
good plan actually
very comprehensive plan it speaks about
wildflower meadows and all sorts and
talks about
a proper maintenance plan over five
years and beyond that
a separate company would be empowered to
do that
uh as i said covers future management of
all the landscaping including
replacements where necessary
now i did say i'd like i would like to
add an additional
uh condition and i've been heard what
the agent said
that if this permissions granted they
want to start this ultima
on construction with the first dwellings
ready for sale by summer of next year
for me and i hear what chris has said
about the 106 agreement
but i think we ought to put a condition
in that says
the development to which this permission
relates must be become no later than the
expiration of two years
beginning with the date on which this
permission is granted
and the reason for that is it's
essential that this development is
commenced
within that period or even sooner and
i'll take what the agents
said they hope to start in the autumn in
order to bring forward at the earliest
opportunity
the new service school site that is
critical
for the area for the northern area for
this area of
westwood hall so if we can put that
condition in
uh which reinforces uh
what's in the 106 but i i'd like it put
to this
phase of this site of this development
um the sections showing the top of the
site
i think i don't if chris could just whip
him up a minute the
sections through does does seem to show
those
dwellings up there standing up very high
on that ridge line on the
on the highest point and again if we'd
had bungalows up there
what a different perspective that would
have been up there
uh the pumping station the question this
is i'd take it this pumping station is
for the whole
not just for this site but for the whole
500 dwelling site is that right chris
they will all feed them to that
eventually yeah the pumping station is
for the entire site that's correct
yeah okay um and i've got i've mentioned
the what the existing watercolors which
is
we know is the northern stream um
and i mentioned devon bank on that uh
western boundary
um and also and
counselor locks mentioned the
hours of work for the site i know
they've got to put forward
that they're going to have a compounded
on sometimes your vehicles etc
but i think in with that we need wheel
washing we need a wheel washing facility
so that vehicles coming off that site
get their wheels washed before they come
out onto the baby road
because it's going to be a heck of a
mess along there otherwise
as to what's been mentioned by several
the solar panels gray water
catching catchment uh heat source
heat source pumps all that we cannot
make
developers put these in because the
government haven't put the legislation
in place that would allow us to do it
maybe it is something that we can look
at in any revisions of our local plan
but currently on this site it's a shame
nothing like that is happening
sustainable uh sustainability is key at
the moment
but i'll finish yapping for now because
i don't know if anybody else wants to
come back with anything
nobody wants to comment further on
anything
well we've got a pr we've got a proposal
to grant this
um but i would like that condition if we
are going to i'd like that condition
added
counselor watson you've not spoken yet
um that was a very good speech
to be quite honest chairman i i i've now
listened to it to all this
uh i'm being mainly kept quiet because
it's up to you guys from biddeford or
west widow or
wherever you come from uh but i just
look at
like page 19. flood risk management
on the 17th of the 7th they came back
with no objections
highways of no objection environmental
protection
no objection southwest water no
objection
there are the house the house types
are are quite fine they look quite fine
to me
uh i mean against um
against the backdrop of of bayview road
when you look at bayview road there's
multiple different designs in housing on
bayview road
um the landscaping looks
very good and and i read that report
just like you did
chair which was extremely good
the affordable housing well i'm i'm
afraid that was all set out in
in the outline um
only it doesn't comply with the outline
actually counselor
yeah it does and and the piece of land
that somebody mentioned about
uh that could be offered to uh
the people on bayview road i think that
would end up being a civil matter
um and for me
and we haven't got a five-year land
supply i
for me i would put forward that that
this is
there to propose that this is approved
thank you councillor watson chris do you
want to speak and i'll bring cancer to
the lock-in after that
no problem i will deal with the point
about the conditions
um and then um i think rachel wants to
speak about this section 106 if that's
okay
um so as with as
with councillor lock earlier bringing
that condition i think
we'd have to informative the time that's
already set out in the outline that they
would essentially have to
commence within two years so we could
make reference fire informative that
uh the outline says this and we would
expect you to start within two years
um chris chris because i just stopped
you there
because the outline actually states the
last reserve
matters two years after the last reserve
matters application now seeing as the
outline covers the whole site the whole
500 house site
i want i'm not it's not clear that it
doesn't refer to the last
phase three reserve matters application
going through
i want this phase certainly one
a big and i hear what the agent said
they want to start in the autumn but i
would just like a condition
that two years from the date of the
granting of permission
should be conditioned on this
application
let me just ponder it with sean a second
i can't say ever if that's okay
um in the meantime i'll bring in
rachel um and um if she can discuss the
section 106 review but quickly before
she comes in
with regards to construction traffic
management the condition
already requires wheel washing in
so that's it's already covered so that's
um that's the point but if
so rachel can come in while i quickly
chat with sean and stacy
regarding the time condition that would
be great thank you
rachel yeah hi um yeah i'm just going to
come in on the affordable housing
um mix um in the main it does comply
with the section 186
agreement but i do take your point on
the one bed provision
um you're right that if if we stick um
strictly to
the detail in the section 106 this
should have been seven units
um there were one bed but what the
applicant has done
is provided some two bed flats so in
total we have
uh four one bed flats and four two bed
flats so
eight flats now we can um if
we wish to under occupy those flats to
one bed need
and in the interest of sustainability
often that's what will happen
um particularly if sort of people are
applying in the sort of early stages of
pregnancy and what have you
so um i do however recognize you know
you do have a point but it was
you know the the the provision of two
bed flats in addition to
bed flats was seen as a betterment now
what a rachel what about the square
meterage of these
affordable dwellings the one bed the one
bed two person flat falls below what it
what
should be and so do the three bed five
person house
in square i mean sorry yeah again i take
your point but as a local authority we
it's it's it's a guidance um
we don't have it detailed anywhere in
our policy about space standards at this
current time
so again there's only so so much where
we can enforce this
on in terms of space standards but it
will often be the case because of design
that
uh units are provided a few
meters square under the the recommended
provision
rachel it does say in 106 agreement the
following minimum size requirements
they're in the 106 agreement which is a
leader
it does it says unless otherwise agreed
and um
above this of minimum sizes there is the
paragraphs that says unless otherwise
agreed
and sometimes for dessert design
purposes
is the case that that provision will be
slightly under
um but again you know we are drafting a
new sbd and hopefully this will be sort
of strengthened going
forward um but yeah i do take your point
on that
all right rachel thank you thank you i
don't know if chris wants to come back
but council a lot wants to speak now
councillor locke yeah i was just going
to
um second council watson's proposal
because the highways have got no
objection the flood risk management team
have withdrawn theirs
the environmental protection officers
got no objections
and rachel has endorsed the affordable
housing
so i would second that proposal but
with the additional condition 20 on the
extra play space
an informative on the construction hours
and whatever
mr harrington is going to come up with
delivery um because i do have agreed
accounts of nether that we ought to say
that um phase one of this construction
site has got to be
implemented within two years rather than
wait for phase three
thank you council lock chris and sean
i don't know who wants to speak chris or
sean i'll let sean go he's he's quite
keen i think
thank you chris uh thank you council um
in relation to the condition
of the time if we refer
to the nppg so the national plan
procedure guidance
at paragraph 2025 i believe it is
which talks about what conditions we can
legally actually attached to reserve
mass applications such as this
it's clear that the conditions can only
directly relate
to those reserve matters that are being
considered the time conditions already
been put on the outline permission
and therefore my advice to you would be
that we would not be able to put a
condition
in relation to two years as part of this
reserve matters permission
we can however put an informative
referring back to that original
condition
um in the outline commission could you
just confirm your reading of that one on
six
and the in relation to the actual
communication
yeah uh i mean yeah
i don't want to put you on the spot if
you've not got the yeah
yeah i've got it for me so condition
four the development here by permitted
shall be begun either before the
expiration of three years from the date
of this permission
so that's a wider outline permission for
the whole site or before the expiration
of two years
from the date of approval of the last of
the reserve matters to be approved which
whichever is later but that refers to
the whole 500 house site
not to this first phase
because it could potentially be read
that way yeah well that's why i'd like a
conditioning
that i i accept what the agent said
about they want to start this autumn but
i'd like it but in any way and i think
we should be putting it in
and i don't think there's any there'd be
any objection to that
i mean we all know we all know
with the best will in the world that
we've given planning permissions in the
past
and they've not been done we give three
years usually
and have not happened right up to the
three and the big the crucial issue is
this
is the school site the sooner this site
is started and developed and the service
site for the schools there the sooner
devon county council can approach the
government for funding for the school
they can get the school built and then
when the 106 money comes in for the
school
they repay the government so the school
could be started
you know it might even with the bill a
lot get started towards the end of next
year
but it's critical for the area that this
school gets built
as soon as possible and that's the real
reason i'd like this two-year
from the date of planning permission
being granted on this site and i think
we should put it on for that reason
hi chair can i come in um i think
there's a couple
points which can give us um a little bit
of um comfort
um i agree with sean we we can't add
that condition unfortunately
however there's there's two things
there's two things to consider um
firstly
all of the reserve matters uh need to be
submitted next year anyway so actually
um at that you know the time limit is
actually already short
either way you look at that condition
all of the reserve matters
have to be in um and therefore
in reality they're going to have to
start within that time anyway also the
the way housing developers generally
work is once we grant this plan
permission they're
normally obliged to purchase the site
and would at that point
be making a loss on it until they can
sell houses so
um i think we're fairly confident in
those terms that they
they will probably be keen or very keen
to start building
uh sooner rather than later um if you
want we could get stacey in regarding
the the
the condition but i really would just
emphasize shawn's point
i i don't think we can condition it it's
clear in the planning practice guidance
and i'll leave it there why is it
mentioned in the outline then
so the outline is the plan permission
and then this is just
the reserved matter so it's the
follow-on so the reserved matters have
acquired as a condition to that plan
permission
so the the outline would set out all the
principal conditions such as time etc
and then you wouldn't then uh it
wouldn't then be reasonable to
put those on reserve matters that you're
have sort of indicate frank more report
unfortunately at this stage we're very
limited as to what we can actually
consider and do
council craig he wants to speak and
cancel a lot
thank you chair um i just feel that it's
it's very regrettable that we have to
just go by minimum
standards the fact that all these people
don't object
just means that it's reached the minimum
legal required standards
there's no vision there's no it's not
appropriate for the people who want to
live there's not bungalows
it's not going to improve the
attractiveness of the area it's not
going to give us extra facilities
and i almost feel we're blackmailed over
the school because obviously we want the
school
but you know if they're saying well we
have to approve the houses to get the
school
i just i would like to um you know
not prove it but i feel as if we've been
blackmailed into approving it
it's got it's got no sustainability it's
got no
cycle access pedestrian access
it's got no sustainability on the houses
the whole thing lacks vision it's not
what we want here
and i i just feel we should as a
planning committee we shouldn't be just
accepting the minimum standards we
should be looking
at what we do want and i do wonder if
this northern neighborhood plan i know
it's not
completed but i know that it can be
taken into consideration if it's in you
know
in in progress does it have anything to
say about
what what northern would like to see
here thank you
well it will have but it's nowhere near
yet being
considered really councillor craig
councillor lot you've got your hand up
to speak again yeah well
it seems obvious then that we can't um
put a condition on that it started
within two years
but at least if we could have an
informative that puts the
problem on the map sort of thing so i
would still second the proposal to
approve
with a with two information hours
and the delivery condition date as an
informative if we can't have a condition
all right thanks canceled a lot right
well it's been proposed and seconded
that
this is granted but i would like to know
the confirmation of why we can't make it
a condition i really would
because it's not and it's not it's not
an erroneous it's not you know it is a
condition worth putting on this site
because we want this school site to be
there as soon as possible
and i really don't know what the legal
position is why we legally
if that's what we're talking about a
legal thing that we can't put it on
because i shouldn't be i'll be very
angry if we find out we could have put
this on and we don't put it on
you've got to keep the pressure up on
developers and how to get these things
developed
and this is coming out actually in one
way with with what
generic said this morning on the radio
you know let's get these things built
and done with
fully accepting what the agent said they
hope to start hope to start in autumn
but i mean is this legal or is it not
legal why can't we put that condition on
we are the plans to committee we've got
the authority
yeah sorry i didn't see if you saw my
hand up or not um
i mean we can refer to stacy of course
we've got stacy here our legal officer
in relation to this but i
i don't really want to repeat the
wording that i used previously
um but as chris said the outline plan
commission is the planning permission
and we this application is related to
reserve matters
which was detailed in the condition of
the outlying permission
now the nppg which is our the national
guidance
present placement central government
clearly has a paragraph on this very
issue
which is paragraph zero two five i can
provide you the reference id for that
uh which clearly states that uh
conditions can only put on reserve
matters that directly relate
to the reserve matters to be considered
now the planet
has already been granted by the outlying
planning commission
so a time condition on here isn't
relating to those various reserve
matters
which you've got in front of you as part
of this application um
i don't know if stacy wants to come in
and discuss that from a legal standpoint
uh but that's my view and that's my
professional advice uh to remember
i'm not gonna label there's a point on
that i won't label the point
but it's just what has been highlighted
this morning with this application is
how important the outline application is
i mean we've always said it's important
because once
an outline is granted it establishes the
the fact that that site can be developed
for whatever but
it now transpires with this application
that the types of houses that are going
to go on a site
are stated during the outlying
application so if we'd wanted
bungalows which we do want on this site
it should have been stated at the
outlying stage now nobody ever told
us that we never have been led to
believe that we can do that
but i'm i'm darn sure on sites coming
forward from now we'll be doing it on
outline applications
but the whole site then the phase one
the phase two and three is blighted
with this outline then anyway it's been
moved
to grant it's been uh approved move for
approval by councillor watson
secondly by council a lot sandra can we
go to the vote please
yes chair thank you councillor bowton
um four councillor brown
okay answer christy
thanks
or pencil in the golf
ball cancer watson
or cancel a wise men paul
so that's six
four and three against chair
thank you sandra thank you for that
right we'll move on then
i just need to go to the toilet
not quick five a quick comfort rate for
five minutes then because we've been sat
here
it's 10 to 12 now yeah not a cigarette
break a comfort break
yeah thank you for everybody who's
contributed to this
discussion uh to all the members of the
public
um and the ward member for westwood hall
i mean i'm sure that the the applicant
can realize there
are still lots of
lots of concerns over this site um
and we're forewarned now about phase two
and three whenever they come forward
can't check and i just ask everybody to
mute because we are still live on
youtube
yeah yeah council what someone's not
there to meet now can you not mute them
john
yeah yeah yeah i just didn't think we
should can i
i'll mute everybody check that okay yeah
yeah that's all right
um
um
right well thank you those were watching
us on
live on youtube thank you for bearing
with us well we had that short break i
think
i think everybody's back now yeah
everybody's
back now so we'll carry on with our
agenda
and the next application
is application one oblique 0948
2019 a full application at halwell
junction
and i'll hand over to
who's who's presenting this one
that that's me chad i've highlighted
your name
i think my head's still up dad and hell
i think right
okay thanks if you'd like to give this
presentation
thank you chair sorry can i just say i'm
not sure if councillor mcguff's here
at the moment i saw him
thank you thanks helen
thank you chair and good morning um
members and members of the public
it's just just morning still um
so this application proposes the
erection of
five dwellings at holly lane farm hal
will junction
in attendance i can't see him
yes
okay can i continue yeah carry on yeah
okay just before i i run through the
presentation
and there is a verbal update and a
proposed amendment
to um two of the conditions that have
been put forward
um in your agenda report um
specifically conditions nine and ten
so if if members could turn to page 90
of the agenda report um
so these are both highway conditions
condition 9
is a pre-commencement condition that
requires specific highway infrastructure
to be
provided before commencement of any
other part of the development condition
10 deals with
highway infrastructure being in place
prior to occupation
um certainly after the the virtual site
visit there was
um a question raised over the pedestrian
access along holly holly lane
and so so it is proposed to give extra
certainty
that there should be a requirement for
that pedestrian
route to be provided prior to
commencement right
rather than prior to occupation so the
condition
have simply been been changed whereby
part g of condition 10 is
has essentially been moved up to part c
of condition nine so condition nine is
set out before you on the screen
with amended wording that now requires
that pedestrian footwear
to be provided prior to
commencement okay um
so so that that is the the proposal
that's before you now
um just to give a further update on that
i know there was a question at the
virtual site visit
about um
and suggested issues over the rights
of access and rights of access for the
development the
the applicant has provided some further
evidence of title
certainly on the applicant's part of
point of view which confirms
that they only access and that um
the object has a right of access we
haven't had any evidence to suggest that
that right of access leads the objector
to have
a right to you know refuse the
development access across it so there is
no evidence before us
to to suggest anything other than this
access being available for the
development
um furthermore the agent has confirmed
that given phase one
is well underway the pedestrian access
will be
available as of october so
this condition can easily be met so um
just just to update you all on that
the other update is on the open space
contribution
the agenda report at
page 86 summarizes
the requirements of policy dm10 and the
generated requirements from the
development in terms of open space
this is broken down into both an overall
financial sum
and then specific typologies
there is a commitment within the agenda
report to verbally update
members of the committee in terms of
what aspirations the parish council
might have for how those monies be spent
um
so i have spoken to the clerk of the
parish council
um you will also i'm sure have noted
that the parish council are recommending
um
they have raised concerns over the
proposal so there is you know a slight
sort of conflict there
however if the application is supported
today
then i would certainly as case officer
look to pick that up directly with the
parish council and ward members in terms
of exactly
where those monies are directed it's my
understanding that there is now a
proposal for
a mugger and enhancements to the
children the existing play area so
i'm members can take comfort there are
projects um
but that you know those discussions
would certainly take place
if the application's supported okay
okay so i'll move on through the
presentation now
so um the application site is outlined
in red
on the screen now this is the submitted
site location plan
and the access would be from from the
a3079 which is to the south of the site
the the the red line that comes off
to the east and joins the a3079 that
identifies holly lane where pedestrian
access would be
provided looking at the site in the
context of how well junction
um you'll see the top the top left
corner of this
of the aerial photo shows the site
outlined in red
and you'll see that the site sits at the
north northeast corner sorry north west
um part of howard junction to the north
of the a3079
just zooming in now to have a closer
look at the site and how it relates to
the built form of the settlement
immediately to the south of the site um
is a site that's currently under
development
and phase one it's known as of this of
this proposal
and that does fall within the
development boundary and that is under
construction as
i will show later in the photos this is
the
proposals map for how will so again you
will see the site outlined in red and
how it does
sit outside of the development boundary
phase one of the development immediately
to the south is within the development
boundary
so just to show the context with
with how well at the settlement
i'll just run through some photos now of
the site um
which are very similar to what was shown
on the virtual site visit
so this is a view into the site from the
a3079
you'll see the construction fencing that
is in place and
you know clear signs that that phase one
of the development is underway
um this is just panning round so from
this view
from the a3079 you'll see that phase one
is what is immediately visible the site
beyond you can see the trees right in
the background
that that forms the rear boundary of the
site
towards the north and
this this is from the a3079 so looking
down the hill you can just make out the
fencing beyond
beyond the dwelling that is the point of
access
from the a3079 and here
this is the view so this is holly lane
as it comes out onto the a3079
and then just panning around this is the
point
of access onto the existing public
footwear along the a3079
this is holly lane again so this would
be the pedestrian route which has
already been approved as part of phase
one
um you this is holly lane looking back
down to the a3079 the footwear would be
put in along the right hand
side along the left-hand side of the
highway
um and this is holly lane looking round
towards the site
and the the pub the foot way would be
along sort of the right hand side of the
lane
this is the point of holly lane entering
into the development site which comes in
sort of within the within the
part of the site that phase one is being
constructed on
um this is looking at the very sort of
northern
end of phase one and so the application
site is beyond the buildings that you
can see
um so you can you can kind of appreciate
it is a relatively flat site but there
is a slight incline
as you head towards the north this is
the bottom corner of the site so the sub
southeastern sorry yes southeastern
corner of the site
and the photos will just pan around so
members can appreciate the site
looking from from south to north um
you'll see there is an existing
structure at the bottom southern end
of the site and and then the mature
trees that form the boundary
both along the the western and northern
ends
and that's that's the existing structure
and just this hedge boundary
forms the boundary between phases one
and two
and looking down towards phase one now
just to you know so members can
appreciate that that development is well
underway
um there was clear evidence of that at
the time of my my site visit and
and then looking back round you see
phase one the application site is behind
me now and then the pedestrian access is
close to where the red
vehicle is just just beyond
this is from the top of the site so the
top north east corner
looking back down again you can
appreciate there is a slight
incline as you head towards the north
the access track that you can see
on the left-hand side of this photo
would be retained with a boundary here
so there would still be access to the
the field gate that's at the northern
end um and again this is now just
panning from north down to south so
the the established mature trees along
the boundaries
and and then coming back back round and
up to the top
so that shows it is essentially
an agricultural field at present moving
on to the proposed plans
so this is a site plan proposed site
plan shown in the context of the
approved phase one scheme
members will see that the phase one
development of five
dwellings that has been approved along
with the access onto the a3079
is shown and then the spying road would
continue
up into the application site with the
five dwellings being set on either side
and they they are set within
reasonably sized plots each with two
driveway parking spaces and as you will
see when we look at the
the floor plans and the elevations also
with um
attached garages you can just make out
there is
a attenuation tank for surface water
so the surface water drainage will run
into an attenuation
tank which will then um the out the
outflow of that will be into the
adjoining stream
and zooming in now on phase two you can
get a closer look at the proposed layout
and how the form of the development
essentially carries on from phase one
and is set within that the clear the
existing mature boundaries of that field
um moving on to elevation so plot six
and
seven um all five of the dwellings
are proposed as single-story bungalows
um
they are very similar in design so plot
six and seven
elevations before you now floor plans
show that they there would be three
bedrooms
kitchen diner in lounge and another sort
of features you would expect to see
moving on to plots eight nine and ten
again a very similar design a slightly
different arrangement with the attached
garage
and the floor plans very similar again
these would also be
three bedrooms so all five units are
three three-bedroom bungalows
um so finally the the material
considerations as
as set out in your agenda report um i'll
just run through them very very quickly
the principle of development you will
you will see from the officer report
that yes this is outside of
the development boundary for how well um
however given the current situation with
the private land supply
there is a need to consider this as per
the tilted balance and the requirements
of the mppf
it's also important to note that policy
st 21
is engaged and does enable development
outside of development boundaries
um the design and impact on character
and appearance of the area
an assessment is made of that in the
report raising no significant objection
given the low impact of the dwellings
and the screening
residential amenity conditions are
recommended in terms of hours of
construction
and the need for a construction
management plan
in terms of layout and siting and
proximity between
properties there are no objections
highways
and there are no objections being raised
by devon county council
they have referred to the previous
agreement to the access from the a3079
ecology there are supporting mitigation
and enhancement proposals which which
are set out in the report
foul and surface water drainage again no
objections are being raised those
methods for drainage are set out both in
the plans and the supporting information
planning obligations would be secured
towards education
and open space and as my update at the
beginning
um if members wish to support this
application then engagement would take
place with both
the parish council and the ward members
just to be sure that that open space the
upcoming space monies are
put to the right right projects and and
you know finally the the planning
balance is set out in the report
and the recommendation is one of
approval
thank you helen thank you very much for
that presentation now there are two
speakers to this
application and i hope uh murray
murray ross sorry i hope he's here
he is um he's he's the agent he wants to
speak in support of it
so mr ross you've got three minutes uh
to give your presentation thank you
okay thank you chair um good afternoon
councillors
so my name's murray ross i'm a director
for avalon planning and i'm representing
the applicant
and the the existing site comprises an
area of land immediately
immediately adjoining the designated
settlement of power junction
and located only 640 meters
from the local village amenities the
plot also
joins an extant residential scheme which
you're aware of and which is currently
being developed for five homes
the site before you warrants the
introduction of sustainable housing to
support the vitality of the village
and provide greater choice in family
housing
now the delivery of this site for five
dwellings will be consistent with the
key aims of the howard
uh spatial strategy by delivering on a
modest housing number
which will not preclude future allocated
housing growth
within the village additionally the site
is north of the a3079
in an accessible position and as part of
the observations
there will be improved pedestrian and
cycle access together with financial
contributions
towards open space and education
uh without a five-year housing land
supply it is necessary to consider the
proposal in accordance
with tilted balance and set out in
paragraph 11 of the mppf
in doing so considering proposals also
in accordance with policy
st 21 it is recognized that this
proposal could achieve
um the following assistance in the
delivery of family housing and
contribute towards
lacking five-year housing land supply
being well related to existing housing
at the edge of the village
the development will not be considered
to result in encroachment into the wider
countryside or landscape
the new family housing will support
local amenities schools and
public transport connections in addition
the proposal is readily deliverable with
phase one an extent permission currently
being developed
providing the necessary vehicular and
pedestrian access routes
the delivery of both sites evidently has
wider benefits to the local community
and by grouping the housing in this
location further avoids any encroachment
having spoken with local estate agents
we are aware that the
primary demand is for three version
houses to support growing families
this need is supported by the council's
most recent housing and economic
needs assessment officers have confirmed
that there will be no detrimental
immunity impacts with existing or
future neighbours and the county
highways authority are also satisfied
particularly given that the access route
onto the a3079 is considered safe and
suitable
the site will provide improved
pedestrian access to the village
this accessory is within the control of
the applicants secured within the
ownership of that land
adjoining properties have the right to
pass and re-pass only
over the private access
members will also be aware of the steps
being taken to achieve biodiversity net
gain and these
have been set out in the submission
package importantly buffer zones will be
introduced to protect
boundary habitats and new native species
species-rich hedgerows will be
introduced
to summarize the proposal before you is
considered to comply with the three
strands of sustainable development
are set out in the mppf officers have
clearly indicated the key benefits of
this proposal to the village
and why the community and with these
benefits demonstrate to be
outweighing any address impacts planning
permission should be granted
thank you for your time thank you mr
ross thank you
uh and our second speaker to this is
councillor hackett that's he's here
so councillor hackett as board member
it's now yours
turn to put your presentation
good morning committee thank you very
much chair
as district councillor i represent the
ward
abroad heath and living locally i am
very familiar with the application
site the extensive planning history
and crucially the relevance of the
proximity
of the a3079
the prevailing road conditions
circumstances
which would not normally be appreciated
from a virtual site visit
have relevance as the entrance to the
site
is located in a dip in the road entering
the speed limit
for howard junction which is the main
arterial tourist route
from the a30 to bude
many of whom are completely unfamiliar
with the area
how will junctions suffers greatly from
speeding motorists
evidenced by numerous complaints to the
parish council and the police
the community has an active speed watch
you have before you a petition of local
residents
you may feel that a petition of over 60
people
may carry limited weight however
i ask you to consider the death of a
local resident
who was knocked down and killed while
cycling along this road
beyond the entrance to the village
there have been other fatal motor
accidents on the a3079
around how well with cars losing control
and the bridge being hit
weather plays a part so does speed
speed kills the parish council draws
your attention to the speed of the road
and the build-up of water at the site
access
in the dip in the road
this objection is considered and
evidence-based
i turned to the principle of development
the primary consideration in making your
judgment
on the application before you it
is outside the development boundary
accordingly the provisions of part 4
of policy st07 apply
in the country
side development will be limited to meet
local
economic and social needs
this application site is in
direct conflict to policy st07
accepting that the application site
adjoins the development boundary for how
policy s t 19 has relevance
it has specific criteria which have to
be met
with a proof of evidence for this
exception site to qualify under policy
st 19
exception sites providing affordable
housing
for local needs i
ask you to have con consideration of
torridge council's
own strategic enabling officers
submission before you
as a housing needs assessment
has not been submitted i am unable to
support this application
at this time shamefully
this application delivers not one
affordable home
to the local community on a flat green
field
site therefore the application falls to
the first hurdle
there is no principle of development
under policies st07 or st
19
with regret despite torridge's best
endeavors
the appeal has found that we do not have
a five-year land supply for housing at
this transitory moment
applications hostile to the local plan
and the good of the area
are to be considered disregarding
damning country evidence i turn to
planning condition
10g a subtle but imperative change to
the
drafted condition is required as it
needs strengthening
the current condition states in effect
that the footwear along holly lane
linking to the existing footway
be completed prior to occupancy
i ask that this be amended to read
before any construction takes place the
footwear
be completed and signed off
as king knut could not hold back the
waves
the lack of a footway would be a
difficult justification
with five houses completed and lying
empty
in summary before you we have a site
encroaching on open countryside
which delacts any principle of
development under policies sd07
and st 19 delivering not
one affordable house furthermore the
plans committee
have been put on notice of the
fatalities and the dangers of the ao379
the strength of local opinion against
the site
which has the potential to cause
considerable
and permanent harm to our community
which we as councillors collectively
and individually represent
committee i call on you to reject this
application
as it is contrary to all planning policy
thank you very much committee thank you
chairman
thank you councillor hackett i wish you
to just parked up for
five minutes while you gave your
presentation because you did
break up a little bit but we did we had
got your
emailed uh statement anyway so we were
able to follow you all right
thanks for that councillor hackett right
well that's
that that's the last speaker so
i'll open it to debate by the committee
now
station council we're nearly up to the
three hours so this might be an
opportune moment
just to do the vote to extend past the
three hours before members
start debating all right thank you
thanks stacy we'll do that
sandra could you i'll propose that we do
go beyond three hours
who will second that please i'll second
it counselor watson send it
if you could go through the members and
ask them to confirm that please
yes thank you chair councillor bowton
at four councillor brown four
councillor christy or
pencilla craigie four penciller leather
poor penciller lock
[Music]
that's unanimous chair thank you thank
you sandra
okay who'd like to go first on this
council lock um
if you turn to 73 is the sydney question
i know and some of you might know the
answer
but i'm asking helen the very last
planning application listed has got pco
written by what does bzo stand for
um yes cancel out that that is pending
consideration
right um yeah so i'm not but but
slightly confusingly in looking at that
the same reference appears
two applications up on that list and
indicates it was
yeah indicates it was permitted i i'm
assuming this is
this is all sort of generated from our
system so i think this is just an error
on the system i mean clearly the the
application that's pending consideration
is 0.948 which is the application that's
before you now
so yes that well well picked up
thank you councillor watson yeah thank
you chair
uh first of all i i i should
make it known that i am also
broad east district councillor but this
for this application i've stood away
from it and that's why
philip philippa has done it so i still
come here with a clear and open mind
what i'd like to clarify is
this this um recommendation this
extra recommendation that that we've
we've put in
does it actually mean that they can't
build
anything until the footpath is put in
yeah um let let me just put it back to
the wording
for you sorry i have to pan back through
um sorry bear with me
so yeah essentially that's that is what
we've we've looked to achieve
so um conditions nine and ten are both
conditions that were recommended by the
highway authority with condition nine
being prior being essential works that
have to take place before any other
development can commence
and previously the requirement for the
footway was under condition 10 which was
infrastructure that has to be in place
prior to occupation so
in moving and amending condition nine so
the new
part c of condition nine so the
condition is no part of the development
here by approve shall be commenced until
and part c specifically now refers to
the pedestrian footwear
along holly lane linking the existing
foot
way on the public highway so so
essentially yes councillor watson this
this means that that
footwear has to be in place for use by
the development and then retained
and but certainly prior to commencement
of phase two
it has to be in place before they can
start building
yes yes okay ellen that's fine that's
fine
okay i'll let somebody out
counselor mcgowan very much mr chairman
um i'd like to obviously with the
additional
recommendations that came through the
updates i'd like to supposedly accept
the
application as it stands thank you
thanks councilman golf
well nobody else has put the hand up to
speak on this one but
i love my say on it
it is in the open countryside and it
does stick out like a sore thumb
when you look at that the uh
the view of um that helen put up there
you are
look at it stuck out there like a sore
thumb and
when we had photographs of the site it's
got lovely green boundary treatment of
existing hedgerows and
trees but i've looked in vain to see in
the report that that's going to be
protected
and i noticed the ecology report
speaks however it further recognizes
that the boundary habitats
field heads scrub hedges trees and
watercourse
are of greater ecological importance as
potential habitat for protected species
and as a habitat as habitat does
i echo that absolutely but there's
nothing in the conditions to protect
that
i i noticed that the rest of the site
the blue line
could be a future where they think
they're going to extend through onto
there but
we've got we're only looking at what's
in front of us but i'd like these
boundaries protected
can can helen give me some assurance
that we can put a conditioning that will
appear to
there you are the northern boundary and
um the western boundary i think it is
particularly
um thank you councillor yeah that's you
know a very
very relevant observation the um
the ecology reports and mitigation
proposals clearly indicate a requirement
for both a buffer between the
development and the boundary and the
protection
of the boundaries around the site and
condition
let me just see i think it's the last
condition condition 13
requires an adherence to those documents
and those mitigation measures
you're absolutely right though there is
not an explicit condition requiring
retention of boundaries
around the site and that's certainly
something we can
we can include if you would like a
specific condition on that
i should caution with that um you know
the trees aren't subject to a
preservation order
but if we if we put a condition on then
you know that enforces both the ecology
and requirements and also the the
clearly my recommendation and assessment
talks about
the the limited visual impact and that
a big part of that is the mature
screening so
so certainly we could include that it
just
it goes on in the ecological uh report
to say buffer zones to protect the
boundary
habitats but only during construction
um it doesn't specify what kind of
boundary protection
depth of it or anything but i really
think we should
we should because i think the ecology
report is very good and looking at the
photographs of the site
and this occurred to me when we had our
virtual site visit looking at the
photograph
it really looks a lovely site with that
hedging and trees all around it
and that ought to be protected if this
is going to be approved
but particularly look at that that's
lovely look i think it looks brilliant
there may not be a two deal but i think
we should put a condition in
the northern boundary for sure and i
would say the western boundary i think
that's
the boundary that the stream's on as
well they should be protected in
a buffer zone protecting them a buffer
zone of what
how wide do you want the buffers on two
three meters
um just just to come back on on that
point council leather i mean the
the application is made in full so it's
in detail so we are approving a layout
um just sort of measuring the distance
from the boundary
i mean you're looking at a good 25
30 meters you know in terms of that
buffer so
so it is um sort of looking at you've
got a good sort of
20 meters there because you've got the
stream and the way that the land
the land flows but certainly we can
include a condition requiring
retention of those boundaries and so
yeah
that's that's certainly something we can
do all right well if we can put that in
i'll be happy
i'll go to council a lot now council
lock was the next with the handle
yeah i was going to mention the northern
bound because i note
under the site description on page 74
it says boarded by fields on the north
which are also in the applicant's
ownership
so we don't know what their next move
might be
to go into the field to the north
because they've already had one
application for five
now a second application for five and i
know
and i'm a great advocate on the
statement you only deal with what's in
front of you
but it does make me wonder if there'd be
a next move
and by putting in individual
applications they don't have to put in
any affordable houses
which i'm quite concerned about but i'm
glad to see that we can condition the
northern boundary
and also the changes to the condition
about the lane
so i'll stop there for the time being
thanks council not councillor watson
oh yes yeah well
i i'm i'm really glad that that you you
you brought that up chris uh about the
boundaries because yes
i totally agree with you that we should
do something about that because
ads rose has just set
out it does look possibly that you know
it could go a little bit further into
the other field
uh but i would hope by that time we
haven't got a fight we've got a
five-year land supply
um but okay i'd yes
please let's try and put that condition
in
thanks councilman watson well the thing
is that when we looked at the
photographs it's a very website there's
reeds you know it's a boggy site anyway
obviously i reckon this some brilliant
wildlife around in those hedges and
around the site and i think what helen
says the gardens of the bungalows
obviously there's a natural buffer
because of the gardens but if we
put a condition in to protect that
northern and western boundary
of the existing planting that's there um
okay sean wants to come in on that
uh yeah just as a matter of clarity
chair are you happy that the wording of
that condition is dedicated to officers
in combination with the chair and the
vice chair
yeah i am yeah
right uh councillor mcgosh
council a lot
just one further point on highways i
know i
listened with what council hackett said
um
it's a pity that matt collins is no
longer here because highways don't have
any problems with it
so i'm not sure where to go on the
highways
did i read somewhere that um they were
going to move the 30 mile an hour
sign along that road or is it councillor
watson you'll know exactly where the 30
mile an hour sign is on that road
if you look before you get to the
proposed entrance for this
it is yeah just where if we could we go
back to
to that photograph of the bend the
photograph ellen
looking to the west on the on the main
road
opposite way around keep going
you can see where that you can see where
the fence is
yeah yeah which is the entrance just
around
just around that that bend
there's some bollards and that's where
the 30 mile an hour
starts and it's true what philip says
actually
they do speed through here it's
unbelievable to be quite
honest and there's been three or four
deaths on especially on that stretch of
road where we're the benders
the other thing the other thing
councillor hackett mentioned was
flooding down there in that day
why does that now i assume i would
presume
when they make the entrance to this site
put the road in
that should that should alleviate that
problem in the depth there
well with the drainage of the new road
the
estate road well yeah i'm not sure about
that chair but
but yeah it does it it is just flood
just there
uh been one or two accidents we've put
in there people going too fast
but yeah council unlocked yeah
well we're going you know talking about
the speed in traffic all the time now
speeding traffic is
you know happens all over the place and
i will second council the cost proposal
to accept the
um application with the addition for the
changes to the
conditions about holly lane and the
condition about the boundaries on the
north at the west
thanks council along right it's been
proposed and seconded
that we do grant this application sandra
can you go to the vote please
yes chair cancel about him
at four councillor brown four
councillor christy
councillor craigie or
chancellor leather or counselor lock
or counselor mcgoff or
cancer watson
councillor watson sorry sandra
again against yeah
thank you yeah i don't i don't agree
with this site
okay thank you councillor watson
councillor wiseman
or that's
seven four and two against chair
thank you sandra okay we'll move on to
define an application we've got now
which is
application one oblique zero three eight
two
twenty two and it's listing listed
building consent
um and sarah sarah you're gonna present
this i take it
chair i've got my hand up i want to
declare your hearted interest
sorry margaret jewel hattie dear yes
thank you
thanks margaret councillor brown right
sarah you're presenting this one
chair check can i just mention that
councillor christie has said he
he's going to have to leave the meeting
he has a prior appointment
okay thank you john
right um okay
good afternoon councillors um this
application is being brought to
committee
um the reason is that the um
owner of the property is an elected
member
um the property was unoccupied
um for a couple of years while it was
being sold
and as such is really
in a very it was in a very poor
condition it hasn't really been
modernized
since pre-war most of the fittings in
the rear of the property
are 1930s and the current owner
obviously seeks to bring it up to
current habitable standards
um it is right in the centre
of torrington right opposite the
entrance to south streetcar park um
you could you can probably recognize it
from the previous
photograph which i put on the front
cover
and the works to bring it into habitable
standard are mostly works of repair and
maintenance
which we would agree um as
works of repair maintenance that don't
need permission however there are
certain elements which are mentioned
in the report which go beyond repair
and actually seek to alter the building
and therefore
listed building consent is required now
these are the floor plans which
the changes are concerned with the
ground floor the upper floor
is not being altered at this point at
least
but there are no proposals the basic
proposal we have before us
is to make the ground floor function in
a contemporary way in other words to
provide
a modern kitchen which at the moment it
doesn't have
the kitchen is more or less in the
utility space that we can see
there are other changes which are
desperately necessary where
the back um bathroom and uwc
facility is grafted onto the back of the
property
and was done so in the 1920s from the
look of it and it's all clad
in the contemporary wonder material of
asbestos so that needs to be removed
quite urgently
um the main changes
are concerned with the front room
uh the front two rooms where the
existing chimney pieces
are going to be retained but the infill
which are later
is thought to be removed so that wood
burning stoves can be fitted
and the major change is at the rear of
the property
in what is currently not a kitchen in
in the way that we would recognize it
but
the um owner now seeks to fit a modern
type kitchen
and this will involve removing the
fireplace which as you can see
is um at the period of the previous
phase of improvements on the property
it's frozen at that point
so that fireplace will come out and and
the fireplace behind will be opened up
to give space
and the cupboards on either side of the
fireplace will be removed to allow
a fridge freezer to be placed on the
right hand side and basically cupboard
space on the left
now i think it would be quite useful if
helen could you scroll back to the floor
plan for me so
helen is very kindly operating the
system you can see it
on the floor plan the kitchen has a
multitude of doors and windows and very
little wall space
to put anything so in fact
there is a very tiny section of wall
therefore the owner currently seeks to
use
the um cupboard beside the blue door
and the cupboard that's on the wall to
just provide
extra storage space which you would need
in a kitchen
and that really is the the bulk of the
the change that affects the historic
fabric
this building is very well blessed with
these rather lovely cupboards
um and being joinery it can be removed
and reinstated at a later date if that's
necessary
the owner obviously makes the comment
that
um to make a kitchen elsewhere in the
property would
require moving walls rather than kitchen
cupboards and that's been completely
accepted in
in our considerations um
and therefore the the proposal as it set
forward is accepted
um and i've put this in the report this
time members because i
i never do and i always forget and i'm
rummaging for my
quote in considering the list of
building consent the duty of the council
as the local planning authority is set
out in paragraph 16
of the planning listed buildings and
conservation areas act 1990
the duty in relation to the list of
buildings is to preserve its setting
or any features of special architectural
or historic interest
which the building may possess in this
case
the the um application is supported by a
heritage statement
which is is particularly thorough and
the consideration of the conservation
officer is that
on balance that this proposal is
acceptable and
actually reversible and therefore um
permission should be granted
thank you sarah who would like to start
on this one please counselor watson
yes thank you chair obviously
um he's gone through it uh really well
and and thought things out i totally
agree this
is this has only got to make the
position
of this property in in torrington
to make torrington look a lot better and
i will i will support his application
uh and and i'll recommend that we grant
it
thank you council watson councillor
brown
well thank you chair um the town council
has no objections and really pleased to
see that this old house is
going to be fit for a family in the
future i do want to thank sarah because
she does
great reports on these old houses um and
i would like to second the proposal to
grant chair
thank you thank you councillor brown
well as sarah said the the main feature
that'll be taken out of the cupboards
either side of the fireplace in the
kitchen
and opening taking out that 1960s
tile [ __ ] place and opening up the
thing but as
sarah also said they can be replaced at
a later date if
if necessary but it's been canceled a
lot you want to speak on it
yeah i was just going to say i read the
great interest heritage statement but it
all through cover to cover and looked at
the photographs
and i would support the application i
just like to say the council's in the
bright
good luck with all the work you've got
to do
[Laughter]
perfect right unless anybody else wants
to comment it's been moved
to grant moved by councillor watson
seconded by councillor
brown sarah could you go to the vote on
it please
yes chad cancel about him
at four chance lebron four
counsellor craigie for
councillor leather or counselor lock
or hansel mcgoff or
cancer watson four it's a wise men
four that's unanimous chair thank you
thanks sandra right we'll move back to
the agenda now
agenda uh item eight is appeal decision
summary
there are no appeal decisions currently
nine on the agenda is costs on appeals
there's no costs and appeals to report
item ten is delegated decisions they're
agmb
applications and they're on page 98
and one refused them on approved
so we'll move on from those then to
planning decisions
which are on pages 99 to 107
i'll go through the pages 99 100
100 101
102 103
104 105
106 and you see permitted prayer
notifications there and
and from the bottom refused and there
were three there that are refused
and nobody wants to make a comment on
them council lock's not got anything to
comment
on those at present we've had a long day
i'll i will explain
thanks council a lot right
um right that's it that's the delegated
decisions and that's the last item on
the agenda then for this morning so
thanks very much committee thanks to the
members of the public
who've watched and stayed with us i hope
you've
if you've never watched a meeting before
you've not been too but off without it's
drawn out but the the long debate went
on obviously on the dad and hill one
and of course we've had one removed so
uh deferred so
that i declared the meeting officially
closed at
well quarter